bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour suivre
le temps fort de la semaine au sénat les
questions au gouvernement
dans une heure les sénateurs vont
interpeller l'exécutif avec beaucoup de
questions consacrée à la situation
sanitaire
on va tout vous expliquer avec notre
équipe de journalistes avec steve
jourdain dans l'hémicycle du sénat et je
le disais steve encore beaucoup de
questions autour du cou vie de cette
semaine et pour cause on ferme les
écoles ou bien on les laisse ouvertes on
reporte les élections départementales et
régionales prévues au mois de juin ont
bien on les maintient voilà un peu la
teneur des questions qui seront posées
cet après midi au gouvernement on les
attend avec impatience avec nous salle
des conférences
alexandre poussa pour toutes les
réactions des ministres et des sénateurs
alors quel est votre programme
aujourd'hui alexandre bonjour tam et
bien on va parler de la loi séparatisme
puisque le débat au sénat hier soir a
commencé très fort les sénateurs ont
interdit le port de signes religieux et
donc du voile pour les accompagnants de
sorties scolaires également pour les
mineurs les sénateurs ont également
permis l'interdiction du burkini dans
les piscines
on en parlera avec jacqueline eustache
brinio la rapporteur du projet de loi au
sénat
à tout à l'heure alexandre est enfin
jean mathia notre ce thriller politique
qui suit toute cette séance avec sa
communauté sur la plateforme switch on
est suspendu jean au moindre indice que
le gouvernement pourrait donner cet
après midi et ben oui tu t'en doutes tam
quelques heures après le conseil de
défense et quelques heures avant
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron des
internautes attendent de cette séance de
questions au gouvernement qu
éventuellement les sénateurs et les
sénatrices arrache du gouvernement
quelques informations sur ce qui nous
attend
ouais c'est une mission difficile c'est
ce qu'ils espèrent également les
sénateurs et les sénatrices dans une
demi heure
notre face à face le président du groupe
de la majorité présidentielle au sénat
françois patriat face à la sénatrice
communiste laurence cohen
on va revenir sur la situation sanitaire
on le disait emmanuel macron qui
s'exprime ce soir à 20 heures après le
conseil de défense qui s'est tenue ce
matin on attend les ultimes arbitrages
du chef de l'état
nouvelles restrictions fermeture des
écoles
débat avec votre noter le est prévu au
parlement demain on en parle dans une
des meilleures mais d'abord faut-il
reporter les régionales et
départementales les élections doivent se
tenir au mois de juin c'est ce qui est
prévu mais peuvent-elles être maintenue
à cette date on en parle avec quatre
invités avec éric kerrouche bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste
des landes membre de la commission des
lois vous aviez notamment proposé le
vote par correspondance pour cette
échéance électorale
vous n'avez pas obtenu gain de cause on
va voir si vous revenez sur ce terrain
stéphane le rudulier est avec nous au
sénateur et l'ère des bouches du rhône
vous avez notamment été le rapporteur de
la loi organique sur la prochaine
élection présidentielle et en visio
qu'ovide oblige nous sommes également
avec anne sénéquier bonjour vous êtes
médecin chercheuse co directrice de
l'observatoire de la santé mondiale de
l'iris et nous avons le plaisir d'être
avec le politologue stéphane rozès
président de cap
merci à tous les cadres d'être avec nous
retour d'abord et bien sûr le rapport du
conseil scientifique dévoilé lundi soir
il choisi de ne pas choisir de ne pas
trancher sur cette question politique
laisse le gouvernement décidée sur le
report
quant au gouvernement il aimerait bien
partager cette décision avec les
parlementaires csu 6o des préconisations
mais pas d'avis définitif le conseiller
scientifique n'a pas tranché sur un
report ou non des élections régionales
en juin dans son avis ils renvoient la
responsabilité aux politiques
une décision qui n'étonne pas hervé
marseille le président du groupe
centriste au sénat
le conseil scientifique
procédez un principe simple que
j'appelle le principe de chevalier
laspalès c'est vous qui voyez
et donc comme prévu il ya un retour à
l'envoyeur
et maintenant c'est au gouvernement de
décider
alors ya fort à parier que le
gouvernement maintenant va se tourner
vers le parlement
le parlement sollicité par un vote
françois patriat y est favorable
pour lui il faut même aller plus loin et
consulter tous les responsables
politiques surtout ceux qui seront en
première ligne pour organiser cette
élection
les maires si on prend des décisions
sans que les maires qu'ils puissent le
faire alors ça sera peut-être encore
contester ou mal prévu donc je crois
qu'il faut qd elle prend le temps de la
concertation
marlène schiappa ministre en charge de
la citoyenneté assure en tout cas que le
gouvernement ne peut décider seul
on sait très bien que si le gouvernement
dit nous on veut à tout prix les
maintenir en juin il ya des gens qui
vont nous dire maintenant il faut les
reporter pourquoi voulait maintenir
c'est pas raisonnable etc
et si on dit nous on veut absolument les
décalés vous avez des gens qui vont vous
dire pourquoi vous les décalés c'est
louche c'est une manipulation etc
on est soupçonné dans tous les cas si
vous voulez donc moi je crois que cette
décision doit être collégiale partager
partager la décision selon les
informations du canard enchaîné
dès demain le premier ministre pourrait
proposer le maintien des élections avant
d'organiser un débat dans dix jours au
parlement
bon c'est encore le grand flou sur cette
question eric kerrouche 1 vous vous êtes
sur quelles lignes déjà sur la question
du report est ce que vous souhaiteriez
plutôt un report ou non ça je ne peux
pas vous le dire c'est au gouvernement
de me le dire puisque c'est exactement
ce qu'on lui demande c'est quoi la
difficulté l'individu et les positions
vous personnel sur l'oeuf sur le sujet
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de vous
l'expliquer dans la dans la méthode
c'est la façon dont il aurait fallu
faire et là où on en arrive c'est un peu
comme pour les mac ça pour les masques
pardon pour la campagne de
de vaccination on a proposé depuis plus
d'un an et demi maintenant au
gouvernement d adaptation qui ont été
mises en place dans d'autres pays
ce que rappelle d'ailleurs le conseil
scientifique de manière assez cruel
temps d'en parler dans la plupart des
démocraties occidentales
il y a eu d adaptation du droit
électoral pour faire en sorte que les
gens puissent participer voire des
innovations en ce qui concerne les
campagnes on a fait ses propositions
depuis maintenant un an et demi je le
répète j'ai fait plusieurs propositions
de loi et on en arrive roues et bien le
gouvernement systématiquement sur les
municipales sur les départementales et
régionales les présidentielles a écarté
toutes ces solutions alors que justement
c'était celle qu'ils pouvaient garantir
la tenue des élections dans de bonnes
conditions
maintenant c'est quelle adaptation
va-t-il trouver pour respecter les
délais qu'il a lui même fixé je le
rappelle mais si on reste comme cela
pour vous du coup les conditions sont
pas réunies pour pouvoir faire
normalement cette élection je je dis
juste je dis juste que on s'est privé de
moyens pour que ça aille encore mieux
c'est c'est aussi simple que ça on s'est
mis dans des difficultés tout seul c'est
pour ça qu'on se pose la question je
suis pas sûr qu'il faille se la poser
mais on est amené à se la poser à cause
du gouvernement stéphane le rudulier
vous allez être consulté les présidents
de groupes doivent être consultés sur le
report ou non de cette élection même
question vous ak quel scénario est
défavorable écoutez le gouvernement se
trouve dans une situation
particulièrement difficile tant d'un
point de vue sanitaire que d'un point de
vue juridique le report des élections
départementales et régionales s'il doit
être envisagée ne pourra se faire qu
entre septembre et octobre de cette
année c'est votre deadline mais c'est la
deadline notamment de la constitution
rappelle qu'un article 3 de la
constitution qui dit qu'il ya égalité
devant le suffrage des citoyens français
vous n'imaginez pas reporter les
élections départementales et régionales
après 2022 il faut un motif d'intérêt
général impérieux quel serait le motif
du report après après l'élection
présidentielle est donc la dernière
solution ce serait de repousser
l'élection présidentielle et l'ins pas
possible vous tombez sur l'article 7 où
il faut modifier la constitution des
frais médicaux en cascade il ya des
problèmes juridiques en cascade au delà
des problèmes sanitaires et des
modalités de vote je rejoins éric
kerrouche il faut véritablement
retravailler sur les différentes
modalités de vote pour justement doper
la participation mais en même temps mais
c'est encore positif pour des élections
pour le mois de juin entend déjà bien
distincts si juridiquement ça va être
très court je vais en fait quasi
impossible très compliqué mais il ya
aussi le déroulement de la campagne
électorale parce que si emmanuel macron
décide de faire un confinement strict
pendant un mois un mois et demi
que restera-t-il aux candidats comme
temps pour faire de la campagne de
terrain donc il faut trouver aussi des
nouvelles modalités de participation à
travers notamment les nouveaux médias
internet
on parle beaucoup de réunions zoom mais
je pense que les français ont été
habitués avec le télétravail
il serait bon aussi de trouver ces
innovations en matière de campagne
électorale on va parler un campagne
modalités de vote
on va rester pour l'instant sur cette
question vraiment du report stéphane
rozès on sent aussi on l'a entendue dans
le reportage de cécile siksou que la
majorité présidentielle a envie de
partager la responsabilité avec les
oppositions c est ce que pour vous
actuellement le gouvernement essaye
aussi un petit peu de coincer les
oppositions dans ce contexte pas
forcément de coincer mais vous l'avez
dit le co partager la responsabilité
d'un choix peut-être pas tendre comme
l'a dit marlène schiappa pour éviter des
reproches mais pour trouver le bon
équilibre entre impératifs sanitaires
est impératif démocratique
dans la mesure où cette fois ci
contrairement aux municipales qui a
laissé un tre m un traumatisme au fond
le conseil scientifique n'a pas voulu
prendre parti il a envoyé aux politiques
le soin de prendre la décision et donc
l'exécutif effectivement se sent obligé
de faire appel pour cette fois à la
consultation de la représentation
nationale parlementaire donc
effectivement l'exécutif ne se sent pas
de prendre seul la décision
anne senequier qu'est ce que l'on peut
espérer s il y à un report est ce que on
peut espérer que ça puisse se passer
mieux à l'automne que si on maintient au
mois de juin
par exemple en espérant qu'on pourrait
être plus nombreux à être vaccinés est
ce que ça peut on peut espérer que ça
améliore la campagne et le vote par
exemple ont une manière générale le tout
à fond il faut toujours espérer le mieux
que ça soit avec l'élection ou autre
qu'est ce que peut nous apporter des
élections à l'automne plutôt que là au
mois de juin
gagner du temps sur la stratégie
vaccinale arriver à une bonne moitié de
la population des adultes en france
vacciner ça ne suffira pas de toute
façon pour unité collective ce qu'on le
voit bien d'ailleurs dans ce rapport du
conseil scientifique qui estime unimilk
et vaccinales 70% bien au delà jusqu'à
80 % tout en sachant qu' on n'a de toute
façon 23% en france de miller qui est
exclue d'arrivée juste aux 80 % de
toutes façons d'éviter collective à il
ya aussi ce variant ongs et qui prend de
plus en plus de place qui aujourd'hui
représente 80% de l'incidence des
nouveaux cas donc on voit pour l'instant
où on est dans une dynamique positive et
c'est ce qui finalement implique cette
réserve du conseil scientifique de dire
choisissez une stratégie mais si vous
choisissez une fratrie flore déroulé
outil pour que cette stratégie soit
gagnante aujourd'hui se dire on reste
comme ça et on applique pas de mesures
qui vont permettre de faire vraiment un
frein drastiques sur la circulation du
virus
effectivement au mois de juin c'est
compliqué d'imaginer des élections tels
qu'on les connaît et après je pense que
c'est intéressant de regarder hors de
nos frontières puisque des élections
habitude d'aller voter dans les écoles à
être avec le pour aller dans l'isoloir
mais on voit bien qu'il ya eu des
drive-in les drives une vélo qui ont été
mis sa touche seulement des
dédoublements de scrutin dès l'élection
en plein air sur plusieurs jours
différents donc bien sûr que ça engendre
une logistique et les difficultés
supplémentaires
mais peut-être que le côté électorale
devra devra justement ce challenge est
sûre sur ces défis là pour arriver à
proposer une élection et suivre le temps
de la démocratie
malgré l'urgence sanitaire actuelle elle
est on va parler et bien justement un
des conditions un petit peu concrets de
comment faire campagne de comment voter
d'abord une nouvelle réaction salle des
conférences avec alexandre poussard vous
êtes avec le sénateur et l'ère olivier
paccaud sénateur de l'oise effectivement
tam olivier paccaud sénateur de l'oise
est également élu départemental au
conseil départemental de l'oise vous
vous représenter aux prochaines
élections départementales
comment vous imaginez votre campagne si
jamais le scrutin et maintenu en juin
comment vous allez faire campagne
très objectivement ça va être compliqué
alors là la démocratie à ces rendez vous
ce sont les élections et donc un
décalage pose problème mais il faut que
ce rendez vous se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions
c'est comme un bal sans musique ça va
pas la musique du rendez vous
démocratique c'est la campagne est
actuellement nous ne pouvons pas faire
campagne nous ne pouvons pas organiser
de réunions publiques
les rassemblements même en comité
restreint sont transcrits donc il ya un
vrai problème d'organisation de campagne
c'est évident car une campagne
uniquement numérique ça ne suffit pas à
exclure une partie de la population bien
évidemment bien évidemment que ce soit
en zone rurale ou en zone urbaine tout
le monde
n'est pas équipé et tout le monde n'est
pas intéressé par les nouvelles
technologies de la communication donc
rien ne vaut le contact direct et le bon
vieux papier aussi et dans les
conditions actuelles nous ne pouvons pas
faire campagne il faut en être conscient
donc pour vous cela entraîne
inévitablement un report de ces
élections au moins au moins 70 ans quand
la vaccination sera un peu plus avancé
très sincèrement il ya encore quelques
semaines j'étais défavorables au report
aujourd'hui je pense sincèrement que il
faut se donner quelques semaines
supplémentaires
il ya une autre problématique qui n'est
pas évoquée mais qui est très important
dans les zones rurales c'est
l'organisation du scrutin en lui-même à
savoir que dans des petites communes où
vous avez des bureaux de vote exigu il
va devoir dans le jour du vote y avoir
deux bureaux et pour beaucoup de maires
ça pousse question ils ont sollicité
leur préfecture pour savoir s'ils
pouvaient utiliser la salle des fêtes
qui étaient plus grandes plus facile à
sécuriser de manière sanitaires on leur
interdit donc dans la logistique elle
même
il y a un problème qui n'a pas été pensé
et puis il ya un contexte de crise
sanitaire
ce contexte est ce qu'il va favoriser
bien une prime aux élus sortants avec
cette volonté finalement de garder les
équipes en place
oui on l'avait déjà vu d'ailleurs pour
les élections municipales
les sortants sont souvent revenus
renforcée de ce scrutin
parce qu'ils ont une notoriété que le
concurrent conquérant n'aura pas donc il
ya une petite rupture d'égalité entre
guillemets entre les candidats c'est une
évidence oui
et sur le fond est ce que dans cette
campagne ça permet de parler d'autres
sujets que de la question sanitaire est
ce que ça ne lutte pas d'autres sujets
importants pour l'avenir dans
département
oui aujourd'hui nos compatriotes sont
polarisées malheureusement ou pas sur la
problématique sanitaire qui voilà qui
paralyse entre guillemets leur vie
quotidienne
merci beaucoup olivier paccaud pour
votre réaction c'est imbattable
merci merci beaucoup alexandre éric
kerrouche vous entendez un petit peu
tous les arguments que développe olivier
paccaud le rapport du conseil
scientifique préconisa dématérialisation
de la campagne je cite ce rapport il
importe d'encourager au maximum usage de
moyens d
réalisée lors de la campagne électorale
mais vous et on voit ça peut aussi poser
un certain nombre de difficultés une
égalité d'accès au numérique par exemple
le disait olivier paccaud écouter -
contrairement au président de la
république je suis pas évident
épidémiologistes donc j'ai lu le rapport
du conseil scientifique qui nous dit que
il y a des raisons de faire en juin il y
a des raisons de faire en septembre qui
ne sont pas les mêmes et que donc encore
une fois c'est un choix politique pour
faire un choix politique
il aurait fallu encore une fois mettre
en place des outils qui permettent
d'accompagner le déroulement des
élections
ça a été fait ailleurs nous sommes hélas
juste sur la sur la campagne nationale
d'action du champagne en elle même en
parler vous le dire différement des
élections qu'elle souhaitait quand elles
auront lieu
et quand elles pourront avoir lieu en
fonction de la décision du gouvernement
elles ont lieu ailleurs ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que son petit fils est
une difficulté mais je crois que bien
entendu que les problèmes économiques et
sociaux domine en ce moment pour tous
les français et je le comprends très
bien mais ils continuent à aller
travailler
les écoles continuent à être ouverte on
s'est adapté dans tous les compartiments
de la vie
pourquoi pas dans le compartiment dans
le compartiment démocratique le problème
c'est que le gouvernement a refusé de
donner les bons outils et c'est ça la
vraie difficulté mais je le répète vous
l'avez dans le rapport du conseil
scientifique notamment ailleurs il y a
eu des élections donc non seulement des
votes et également des campagnes
stéphane rozès est ce que vous estimez
qu'on peut intéresser les français cette
campagne y compris enfin surtout si elle
est complètement dématérialisé alors
c'est déjà une échéance qui va avoir du
mal à mobiliser dans le contexte
sanitaire est ce que c'est possible dans
ces conditions qui forcément seront
différentes de celles que l'on a
habituellement pour une campagne
électorale savait difficile vous savez
autant les élections municipales sont
avec la présidentielle l'élection la
plus investie par nos concitoyens parce
qu'il ya des éléments de proximité de
très grande confiance à l'égard du maire
du coup ya une très forte notoriété
autant
intéressée aux campagnes régionales qui
ressemble au fond à des campagnes qui
met en jeu
non pas tant des personnes d incarnation
d esprit des lieux mais plutôt des
tendances politiques des formations
politiques du fait même du mode de
scrutin est très content et d'intéresser
les citoyens dans les conditions qu'ils
viennent d'être mentionné effectivement
moi j'ai eu accès à un certain nombre de
sondages comme signé ou confidentielles
en région il ya une prime accordée au
fond ce qui est intime biais aux
majorités sortantes parce
qu'effectivement une campagne électorale
c'est le moment où on met les uns et des
autres sur la même ligne de départ
on n'oublie pas ce qui a été fait par la
majorité sortante mais il ya une sorte
de reset qu'on retrouve dans tous tes
les élections où on va au fond comparer
des projets des visions des perspectives
et de l'intensité de la campagne dépend
du coup d'égalité des conditions des uns
et des autres pour se présenter devant
l'électeur et puis enfin il ya une prime
au plus mobilisés on l'a vu aux
municipales sont arrivés des maires dans
un certain nombre de grandes métropoles
n'était pas attendue mais qui ont
bénéficié d'un billet de participation
pénalisant notamment des plus âgés je
rappelle que la moitié des legs de rab à
plus de 50 ans
veut dire une pénétration plus
importante des populations vaccinées
mais qui veut dire de toute façon un
billet de participation donc
formellement mieux vaudrait
effectivement des élections en septembre
les présidents sortants notamment de
droite d'où sans doute la décision de
xavier bertrand voulait une stalle
unités de calendrier d'où sa décision de
se présenter tout de suite à
présidentielle de ça de ne pas être
dépendante psychologiquement du
bon-vouloir présidentielle mais il ya un
besoin je dirais d'un horizon de sorte
qu'au minimum ces régionales se passe
bien alors qu'il faut le dire les
municipales ont été complètement biaisé
pas seulement pour des raisons
sanitaires mais pour le x complètement
baroque de saucissonner le premier le
second tour alors qu'une élection à deux
tours c'est un rite c'est pas un acte
administratif
une élection c'est un remake politique
et ce n'est pas un acte administratif
oui comme ça par des des choses
dématérialisée non ce dont on se
déciderait donc il y a voilà y'a les
traditions qui marque le rudulier alors
stéphane redescend pas là il va y avoir
un dock un certain nombre de biais si on
maintient l'élection un petit peu plus
tôt dans des conditions inhabituelles on
peut aussi se dire que ça fait peut-être
partie des nouvelles règles du jeu et
qu'il faut aussi s'adapter à la
aux conditions sanitaires et qu' il faut
absolument pouvoir organiser en temps et
en heure ce type d'élection oui mais
encore une fois est-ce qu'on a les bons
outils
à l'heure actuelle pour que le scrutin
se déroule dans de très bonnes
conditions et qu'on ait un taux de
participation qui ne remettent pas en
cause la légitimité encore une fois des
candidats ou du candidat élu sa
sélection avec des bons taux de
participation j'ai eu des conditions
sanitaires
je rejoins effectivement je rejoins
monsieur kerrouche chahuterait élections
à travers l'europe depuis depuis un an
ce que ce qu'ont fait d'autres pays pour
essayer de mobiliser avec d'autres
moyens que des moyens dit tradi dippach
non traditionnels on doit être capable
de le faire ce que je veux dire par là
c'est six aéroports au mois de septembre
octobre
il serait quand même de bon ton puisque
là on aurait peut-être un laps de temps
matériel suffisant pour essayer de
penser de nouveaux outils tant en
matière de déroulement du scrutin que en
matière de campagne électorale il faut
pas que ça soit un report pour rien et
encore une fois il fait travailler
pendant ce temps là la date butoir c'est
vraiment septembre octobre puisque après
ça va se compliquer d'un point de vue
constitutionnel
on va parler de toutes les expériences
européennes mais un mot and sénéquier
parce que tout à l'heure à stéphane
rozès a fait la comparaison entre et
bien les élections municipales l'an
dernier avec on peut le dire la forme de
fiasco que ça a été avec une
interruption entre les deux tours est
aujourd'hui est ce que vous diriez que
aujourd'hui on est quand même dans une
meilleure situation d'un point de vue
sanitaire que l'an dernier parce qu'on a
à la fois ce risque qui a amplifié par
le variant et puis on demande à
commencer la vaccination donc c'est un
petit peu réduit pour vous on est mieux
on est moins bien que l'an dernier
un petit peu les deux fois on est on est
mieux parce que bien sûr le vaccin
existe j'aimerais revenir les vaccins
existent donc on a effectivement
quelques difficultés à amplifier la
campagne en termes méric de nombre donc
pour ça oreilles pour ça bien sûr on est
mieux on est moins bien pourquoi parce
que nous sommes
début avril deux mains et que nous
sommes dans une situation où on
réfléchit un compliment
un confinement avec les chiffres tels
que l'on a aujourd'hui pour qu'il soit
efficace il faut tabler un mois et demi
deux mois donc ce qu'on a vécu comme
comme été l'année dernière et un petit
peu trompeur parce qu on a aussi le
fantasme de la saisonnalité du virus
avec l'été il est moins présent et tout
va bien
ce n'est pas le cas on a eu l'été
dernier aux états unis
toute la région sud avec une seconde
vague vraiment dramatique et aujourd'hui
nous arriver finalement aux portes de
l'été puisque c'est dans trois mois et
faut faire attention à ça avec un niveau
de circulation les râles trop important
vite qu aussi d'avoir un impact sérieux
sur sur l'été et on pourra pas
finalement table et comme on l'a fait
l'été dernier sur et les combler et le
fait de vivre à l'extérieur pour limiter
la circulation du virus au sein de la
population avant la rentrée donc on est
vraiment une dans une dynamique
différente maintenant il ya deux choses
il ya effectivement la vaccination et
d'acceptation l'adoption des mesures
barrières c'est vrai que les français
sont là et on en a assez de toutes ces
mesures barrières l'arrivée du vaccin
parfois on peut faire dire non c'est bon
on va être vaccinés on n'en parle plus
mais malheureusement il ya quand même
encore assez de monde qui trouve
toujours une excuse pour que ne sont pas
concernés soit parce que ils habitent à
la campagne et servir de la ville soit
parce qu'ils habitent près de la mer et
quand il fait chaud il n'y a pas de
virus ou à la montagne et il a l'air
prêt donc et finalement quand on parle
un peu dans toutes les régions on se
rend compte que chacun a une bonne
raison de faire moins d'attention
qu'ailleurs et la problématique elle est
là c'est que si on n'arrive pas vraiment
à fédérer autour de ces mesures
barrières la vaccination ne suffira pas
pour protéger cet été en tout cas eh
bien on ferait peut-être bien dans ce
contexte de s'inspirer des expériences
étrangères en
a parlé depuis le début de ce débat les
élections puissent tenir dans de
nombreux pays depuis le début de l'année
on va regarder les élections dont pas
notamment le conseil scientifique dans
son rapport de lundi donc il ya eu la
présidentielle au portugal les
régionales en allemagne et législatives
aux pays-bas ou encore les régionales en
catalogne toutes ces élections on puisse
tenir avec instinct nombre de
dispositifs au portugal et bien on a eu
le dédoublement des bureaux de vote le
vote par anticipation
ainsi que le vote par correspondance en
allemagne le vote par correspondance aux
pays-bas le vote sur trois jours et le
vote en extérieur on le disait on a même
pu voter à vélo aux pays bas et puis en
catalan on s'est contenté de
l'échelonnement des plages d'horaires
avec et bien un vote qui a eu lieu sur
une seule et même journée et on va voir
les conséquences sur la participation
est bien dans l'ensemble
beaucoup de pays ont réussi à sauver les
meubles un bon pas mal de baisse
portugal -9 points
allemagne - ce type rats mais regardez
les pays bas ont fait + 7 points
en revanche la catalogne et je vous
disais qu'il n'a peut-être pas pris
autant de mesures que les autres est à -
26 points éric kerrouche qu'est ce que
vous en tirer comme conséquence
moi ce que je comprends c'est qu'il faut
en gros soit prévoir un vote par
anticipation une correspondance au
moment un étalement du voile sur
plusieurs jours pour que il n'y a pas
forcément d'impact sur la participation
moi ce que je comprends c'est qu'on a
vraiment été excellent on n'a rien fait
on est les meilleurs fins et c'est ce
qui est incroyable et on le voit quand
même depuis un an et demi c'est de voir
qu'on a des difficultés et ces deux
refusé de refuser ces difficultés ou
d'essayer de les contourner et elle nous
rattrape pas s'étonner de l'avis du
conseil scientifique à un moment donné
où le président de la république à
partir du début de cette année estime
que c'est à lui prendre des décisions
seul ne pas s'appuyer sur le conseil
scientifique
le conseil scientifique lui a rendu la
monnaie de sa pièce avec cet avis dont
on peut tout faire parce
qu'effectivement c'est une décision
politique
maintenant il ya des choses qui ne sont
plus possibles moi je regrette ans que
la droite sénatoriale se soit pas saisie
lors de la mission d'information que
nous avons eu de la possibilité de
mettre en place le vote par
correspondance en moine d'euros il était
encore temps je pense que c'est à nous
de porter ça
je regrette c'est un choix qui leur
incombe maintenant est ce qu'on peut
faire encore des choses
oui le vote sur trois jours que j'ai
proposé également
c'est très facile à réaliser alors oui
ça implique des adaptations mais c'est
une possibilité
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il faut
quand même pas sûr valoriser le moment
du retour je suis dire on a tous été
votés vous passer quand même très
rarement plus de hal et une demi heure
trois quarts d'heure dans un bureau de
vote dans la journée
enfin je veux dire mettaient plus de
temps pour faire vos courses dans le
faut quand même garder en perspective ce
sans avoir peur c'est peut-être bien de
prévoir des meilleurs jours pour être
sensé c'est possible une densité moindre
11 c'est que ça marche mais encore une
fois on en a discuté et la dernière fois
encore avec madame ciapa elle elle ne
veut pas entendre toutes ces
possibilités d'écouté dans ce cas là un
moment donné on les entend de la part du
conseil scientifique
je l'espérais même pas non c'est pas ça
c'est qu'on va demander on va demander
comme d'habitude au parlement son avis
quand y'a plus rien d'autre à faire
voilà c'est ça la difficulté c'était
famille aurait dû laisser pas trop tard
pour prendre ce type de mesures
certaines oui mais par exemple si on
parle de l'étalement sur plusieurs jours
du vote est ce que ça c'est impossible
impossible
non non possible non parce que je veux
revenir sur le
le déroulement des opérations de vote
effectivement dédramatisons également
quand vous allez au supermarché
trois fois par semaine et vous vous
attendez à la caisse vous avez en fait
les mêmes files d'attentes que
classiquement dans un nouveau de vote
donc là aussi il ya aussi de la
pédagogie à faire est de rassurer
également les français par rapport aux
gestes barrières aux gestes sanitaire au
protocole strict qui a été imposé dans
les communes pour que les opérations de
vote se déroule bien mais là où je
rejoins de ce qu'est rouge c'est sur la
stratégie du gouvernement au mois de
juin nous allons discuter d'un projet de
loin constitutionnel qui donnera lieu
soit disant un référendum qui était
prévu septembre octobre
oui vas y référendum pour inscrire
l'environnement à l'article 1 de la
constitution
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
n'était pas anticipé les difficultés
liées à la crise sanitaire
en cent en juin est également en
septembre octobre
donc on complexifie encore la chance
puisque derrière cela si on reporte de
trois mois on aura aussi une collision
par rapport au référendum
donc tous compliqués la stratégie n'est
pas très claire du gouvernement et ils
nous donnent marine donne en dernier
ressort soit disant la main la
possibilité de débattre sur un éventuel
report sans avoir toutes les données et
sans jamais être avoir été consultés
dans les phases antérieures très
brièvement il reste vraiment quelques
secondes stéphane rozès comment
expliquer ça aux français on
al'impression une nouvelle fois que la
france a tardé
à réagir sur ce camp là comme sur
d'autres et alors que l'on voit des
exemples quand même assez flagrant chez
nos voisins européens
vous avez raison ça a été dit au fond
des français comprennent très bien que
la situation soit difficile pour les
gouvernants politiques mais ils
attendent de la cohérence
on peut pas dire qu'on va re confiné
quel que soit le terme et dire bien on
continue comme avant ils savaient et et
ça aussi le problème lors des
municipales il faut envoyer des messages
cohérents donc je vois mal qui est un
durcissement de nos règles de vie
commune d'un point de vue sanitaire
depuis qu'on dise bas les régionales
vont avoir lieu
effectivement ça a été dit sicilia
report il faut trouver des moyens pour
rendre possible et égal ce que vont être
né les régionales je pense que c'est
très important derrière il ya évidemment
la présidentielle et dans le marasme
actuel moral du pays
il est important que les français se
disent qu on n'a pas mis de la
démocratie en suspens et comme le
parlement était sa présentation
nationale n'a pas été sollicité comme
elle devrait la question de la cohérence
pour répondre directement
et tout à fait décisive hansen et qui
est juste le mot de la fin bon il ya ce
qu'on vient on vient d'évoquer ya
peut-être aussi d'autres mesures de bon
sens ne prendre prendre le maximum des
personnes vaccinées pour surveiller les
scrutins faire les dépouillements qui au
minimum que tout le monde soit testé il
ya quand même un certain nombre de
choses concrètes qui passera par la loi
qu'il faudrait prévoir au moins pour ces
élections où il était une fin du monde
font eux mêmes sont sélectionnés les
gens fait aussi proposer une vaccination
pour les gens qui vont être assez fin
justement au niveau des élections en
fait on choisit une stratégie et on met
les outils en passe parce que ça
fonctionne alors bien sûr que ce simple
à dire mais on a encore deux mois pour
préparer cela ça peut être très bien
fait en drive dans l'est dans les zones
rurales à vélo ou en extérieur dans les
cours de l'école
dans les zones urbaines il il ya plein
de choses à inventer et on réinvente pas
la roue on voit bien que les huit
élections qui ont été faits en europe ce
sont déjà plus ou moins bien passé et
c'est peut-être justement sur ce que
disait tout à l'heure monsieur sur le
fait que ces élections régionales et
départementales sont souvent boudé par
l'électorat
une manière un nouvel outil a apporté un
nouveau média pour que peut-être on
puisse s'en servir de manière un peu
plus d'efficacité que ce soit quelque
chose qui soit pérenne dans le paysage
politique français
merci merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
il ya donc des solutions il a donc des
alternatives
il faut les chercher et les appliquer
merci nous ça vous à une demi heure des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
nous sommes toujours à bien avec nos
journalistes avec cendres poussard salle
des conférences
jean massiet sur tweets chez steve urdin
dans l'hémicycle steve on est dans un
moment d'attenté tout le monde est
suspendu aux arbitrages des manières
macron ce soir on annonce aussi un débat
avec vote je le disais demain au
parlement sur les restrictions
sanitaires il va y avoir beaucoup de
questions sur ce sujet cet après midi
ouvertes fermées que faut-il donc faire
pour les écoles de notre pays comme
depuis lundi faut rappeler la règle un
seul cas de cosider c'est toute la
classe qui doit fermer ça c'est pour les
régions les plus touchées par l'épidémie
mais pour certains élus et bien ces
mesures sont clairement pas suffisant
pour certains experts les écoles sont
des lieux majeurs de contamination alors
que faut-il donc faire sur ce point
comme sur d'autres d'ailleurs ans
emmanuel macron va devoir trancher prise
de parole rappelle ce soir 20 heures les
sénateurs
en attendant cet après midi vont essayer
bien de glaner des informations auprès
du gouvernement ils vont aussi faire
remonter et bien les problématiques
qu'ils rencontrent sur le territoire de
leur département et puis autre grand
thème de cet après midi vous en parlait
il ya quelques instants c'est l'épineuse
question des élections départementales
et régionales sur l'éventuel report de
ces élections ces élections elle était
prévue elle aurait dû être organisée il
ya une dizaine de jours elles ont été
reportées au mois de juin prochain pour
cause de crise sanitaire va-t-on doit-on
voter
au mois de juin prochain faut-il au
contraire à les reporter à nouveau ces
élections le gouvernement a annoncé
qu'un débat sera organisé ici même
demain 14h30 mais consacrée à la crise
sanitaire la question des élections ne
sera pas ne devrait pas directement être
abordée en conséquence les sénateurs
vont appeler le gouvernement à ce sujet
cet après midi et ça promet d'être
animée ça promet d'être animée on va
suivre ça avec impatience merci steve et
à toute l on va parler de la situation
sanitaire avec le président du groupe de
la majorité présidentielle au sénat le
groupe r des pays françois patriat m'ont
gêné savait également avec la sénatrice
communiste laurence cohen merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pour ce biais là on va
parler barre de la situation sanitaire
on l'a dit et redit emmanuel macron
s'exprime ce soir à 20 heures après le
conseil de défense qui s'est tenue ce
matin en attendant d'ultimes arbitrages
nouvelles restrictions fermeture des
écoles
le débat est donc prévu au parlement
demain ça sera 14h30 demain au sénat
le résumé de la situation avec solène
boisset emmanuel macron va-t-il annoncer
un confinement strict ce soir alors que
la france a dépassé ce mardi la barre
des 5000 patients en réanimation trois
scénarios sont de nouveau sur la table
parmi eux rendre obligatoires les
évacuations sanitaires des cas graves ou
encore fermé les écoles une mesure
défendue par la maire de paris je pense
que des écoles doivent être fermées
parce que c'est une des organisations
très grande aujourd'hui par exemple sur
paris on a envie en environ vingt mille
élèves tous confondus qui ne sont pas en
classe soit parce qu'ils sont malades
soit parce que les classes sont fermées
huit cent cinquante classes fermées
aujourd'hui ce matin dans les hôpitaux
le taux d'occupation des services de
réanimation frôle les 90 %
le corps médical fait pression sur
emmanuel macron pour resserrer la vis et
demande des mesures plus restrictives
pour éviter le tri des patients est ce
que nous sommes en train de faire un tri
des patients au sens des programmations
oui est ce que nous risquons de faire un
tri des passions beaucoup plus grave que
ça c'est à dire qui va en réanimation
qui est sauvé
oui c'est ce que nous disent les
chiffres et je le crains est-ce que je
suis sûr que ça va arriver
non est ce que j'ai envie de prendre ce
risque non mais ces inquiétudes ne sont
pas partagées par certains médecins qui
dénonce des propos alarmistes
on est sur un plateau à notre activité
est constante avec une petite
augmentation mais en gros on y arrive
une parole qui s'aiment encore plus l'
incompréhension vis-à-vis du discours
scientifique et de la décision politique
une déclaration de jean castex ainsi
qu'un débat et un vote auront lieu
demain devant le parlement pour préciser
les nouvelles mesures annoncées par le
président à 20 heures françois patriat
on a pris donc ce matin qu emmanuel
macron s'exprimer ce soir à 20 heures un
débat au parlement est prévue demain
avec vote les signaux sont claires on va
vers des restrictions sanitaires
nouvelles voire confinement je pense que
l'hésitation peu porté sur le fait
faut-il prendre des mesures drastiques
et coercitives immédiate
on y at il encore la possibilité de
prendre des mesures graduées moi je n'ai
pas les chiffres exacts des meilleurs
territorialisée ou national aussi a
gradué tout ça dans le débat j'arrête
organisés ou non
moi je n'ai pas les chiffres
au terme de la dernière heure qui évolue
tous les jours est-ce que nous sommes
arrivés au pic est ce que les médecins
disent que ça peut encore monter demain
auquel cas ce serait une attention de
être fermées plus aujourd'hui l'espace
public
donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est que le
chef de l'état prenne les bonnes
décisions
jusqu'à présent je considère qu'il a
pris les bonnes décisions malgré tout ce
que j'entends sans doute vous dira le
contraire
mais j'entends comme tel donc y'a des
matins vous charmer le lary perdu
certains parlent de son pari perdu un
jour moi je ceux qui parlent de paris
d'abord avaient parié le contraire un
moment il n'avait pas parié dans ce sens
là non plus le pari qu'ils ont fait à
l'époque était celui plutôt de refuser
le confinement seuls les médecins le
disait à l'époque et encore pas tous
donc je crois que les avis sont partagés
à ce moment là moi je crois qu'on a eu
raison de ne pas faire perdre à la fois
le mois de février aux français à la fin
le travail et l'école aux enfants que on
est aux étions sur un plateau qu'il
fallait respecter l'évolution et voir
encore d'anticiper aujourd'hui s'il faut
prendre des mesures draconiennes pour
l'épreuve elles n'ont jamais été écarté
par le gouvernement
le gouvernement dit tant que je peux
prendre les mesures qui tient
aujourd'hui je les prends et ensuite si
jamais la situation s'est dégradée
d'autres solutions sont possibles en
tout cas eh bien c'est ce qu'estiment
les médecins regardez cette tribune
parue dans libération de patrick boulet
qui est le président du conseil de
l'ordre des médecins
il signe donc une tribune où il indique
monsieur le président en attendant que
nous soyons massivement vacciner partout
où la situation est grave
il nous faut nous confiner pour vous
laurence cohen aujourd'hui et bien
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on en arrive là
alors vous voyez il ya quand même une
sacrée interrogations c'est à dire qu'on
est tous et toutes suspendues aux lèvres
du président macron à 20 heures il doit
prendre la parole et tout le monde
attend qu'est ce qu'il va dire attendu
larbitre à l'arbitrage moi ça ne me va
pas cette façon de gouverner la france
c'est à dire qu'il a tous les pouvoirs
entre les mains
c'est lui qui décide et on al'impression
une fois de plus qui décide tout seul ou
très petites mains avec son exécutif
moi ya un vrai problème c'est qu'on
finit ou pas confiné ça n'est pas ça
vraiment la question la question c'est
que ça fait un an de de pandémie il ya
eu aucun enseignement
tiré de cette pandémie et il n'y a
aucune anticipation
si par exemple le choix est pris de
fermer les écoles
est-ce que des dispositions ont été
prises est-ce qu'on va oui ou non
vacciner les enseignants est-ce qu'on va
oui ou non
développer les tests salivaires pour les
enfants est ce qu'on va oui ou non
déployer des moyens pour permettre qu'il
y ait justement des classes qu'ils
soient des doublés comme les enseignants
n'arrête pas de le dire
or aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
catastrophique parce qu'il ya énormément
d'enseignants qui sont absents parce
qu'ils sont malades et il n'y a pas de
remplaçants et ça c'est partout dans
tout pour voler dans la main préparation
qu au début même si c'est peut-être sur
d'autres sujets comme l'école par
exemple eh bien moi je trouve que si
vous voulez on a l'impression tout à
coup que le gouvernement découvre que là
il va peut-être falloir fermer les
écoles ou pas eh bien écoutez au bout
d'un an
le moins qu'on puisse attendre d'un
gouvernement 1 c'est qu'ils anticipent
et 2 c'est qu'il tire un enseignement de
ce qu'on vient de vivre ensemble or
visiblement ça n'est pas le cas françois
patriat manque d'anticipation vous
entendez l'opposante au sentire d'un
français
on peut souhaiter les décisions les
mesures idéal j'entends bien laurence je
l'entends mais dans le même temps on est
dans une situation où la cites au la
maladie la pandémie change tous les
jours où la donne change tous les jours
ou anticipée n'est pas forcément
répondre qui va se passer demain
le gouvernement dit il pense que vous
êtes d'accord avec moi maintenant au
maximum les écoles ouvertes c'est ce
qu'a fait de mieux la france par rapport
à tous les pays qui nous entourent
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas eu de
décrochage en 2020 comme tous les pays
autour de nous de pouvoir les maintenir
à tout prix pour deux bonnes raisons
un pour les enfants pour leurs
connaissances pour leur avenir pour les
parents pour le travail c'est plusieurs
mesures qui ont planté et le
gouvernement attend il attend parce qu'à
la victime limite pour lire au fait
effectivement peut-être faudra-t-il
fermés ce soir je ne sais pas mais on la
prendra quand on ne pourra pas faire
autrement pour l'instant la priorité
soigner les gens mais aussi préserver
l'intérêt des enfants et s'efface et
l'anticipation note ici passion de dire
on pourrait tout faire aujourd'hui
par exemple la vaccination des
enseignants le gouvernement s'y est
engagé
il s'est engagé lundi voilà quand et
d'eau sont lord affinera les enseignants
quotidien d'un problème mois par rapport
au bardo ici on est dans un évier
j'ai un problème par rapport à ça
justement on dit on n'avons pas
suffisamment de vaccins donc on va
prioriser les publics mais nous par
exemple au niveau de ma famille
politique
qu'est ce qu'on propose ont proposé à le
vider des brevets pour justement pouvoir
produire plus de vaccins
parce que c'est ça la difficulté
produire plus de matchs de vaccins le
gouvernement dit non quand on dit par
exemple
effectivement les service de réa sont en
saturer mais une fois que les patients
peuvent sortir de réa il ya aussi un
problème de lits parce que la même
politique se poursuit de fermeture une
restriction des cantons dit il y as
possibilité par exemple à l'hôtel dieu
d'avoir 80 lits et de pouvoir sortir les
patients et de les accompagner avec un
personnel qui peut les entourent et qui
n'est pas un personnel ultra qualifiés
comme henri à
le gouvernement dit non à chaque fois
qu'on fait des propositions qui sont des
propositions alternatives
le gouvernement n'en veut pas et
aujourd'hui moi je considère qu'il est
le dos au mur donc c'est vrai que c'est
assez inadmissible au bout au bout d'un
an
tout de suite on va écouter bien ce que
disait tout à l'heure le porte-parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent à la sortie
du conseil des ministres
on a senti une forme de mea culpa rare
quand même dans son expression écouter à
toujours regarder avec lucidité et
humilité la gestion de cette épidémie
il ya des choses qui ont été réussis il
ya des points qui lui au moins était il
ya eu des erreurs probablement
je crois que l'important c'est de le
reconnaître et encore il y a quelques
jours ou quelques semaines vous souvenez
dans l'épisode autour de l'attestation
c'est reconnaître quand il ya des choses
qui ne
non pas pour le reste je veux rappeler
que cette pandémie c'est un drame
mondiale elles frappent le monde entier
qu'il ya des morts et que c'est un drame
d'avoir des personnes qui décèdent de
cet équidé que ce que recherche la
france que recherche notre pays ce que
recherchent tous les pays du monde c'est
à limiter au maximum l'impact de cette
épidémie pour connaissez françois
patriat des erreurs tout de même dans la
gestion du gouvernement
on parlait des attestations gabriela
talent mais vous vous doutez bien pas
pas assez de lits dans les hôpitaux ou
encore et bien dans la gestion des
stocks de vaccins dans la priorisation
de vaccination j'entends parler des pays
à côté dans le bouclier s'il n'y avait
la traversée d'une épidémie inconnu
jusqu'à présent dramatique mondial sans
que dans ce parcours il y eu des erreurs
de commises sur le vrai du miracle qui
peut dire aujourd'hui qu'ils pas fait
d'erreur qui peut dire aujourd'hui
moi je suis là quand même que l'année
dernière je me souviens que le président
avait dit quand il avait dit au mois
d'avril on le libèrera les gens le 10
mai on lèvera le confinement
tout le monde était contre il répond
tout le monde l'opposition et des
contenants surtout pas dangereux et il a
bien fait de le faire et quoi qu'il a
dit le 21 je ne continue pas maintenant
parce que nous sommes sur un plateau et
je ne veux pas privé à la fois les
enfants de l'école et les gens de
pouvoir travailler et les gens de
pouvoir vivre parce qu'il ya une triple
données et la tripe et la donne et
sanitaires il a donnée économique et
aussi la donne et psychologique des
français qui aujourd'hui n'en peuvent
plus tenir compte de ces trois
contraintes contradictoires par ailleurs
ça amène à prendre des décisions qui
parfois peuvent paraître pour certains
parfois d'être compréhensible où il n'y
a pas eu d'erreur réel du comesa côté
donc ce que je pense c'est que vous
évoquez la sphère de
l'attestation bien entendu on tourne on
l'a dit je crois que là il ya une
surproduction administratif qui a voulu
trop s'enfuir dans la sphère et ça a été
corrigée dans les 24 heures mais quand
madame merkel dit je bloquerai 5 jouera
pas tout est bloqué et que trois jours
après le dit non je débloque et quels
sont les excuses
on voit bien que tout le monde tâtonne
parce qu on est tout le temps à
l'adaptation
il n'y a pas de bonne réponse il n'ya
que des moins mauvaises réponses
vous êtes d'accord et ça tout le monde
tâtonne si on reprend notamment sur la
question du confinement qui pour
certains auraient pu être anticipés
aurait dû avoir lieu dès le mois de
janvier est ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
font ce procès là l'exécutif
ou bien est ce que vous dites que vous
comprenez pas le choix qui a été fait
que vous exposez qui prend en compte les
facteurs psychologiques économiques en
plus du secteur sanitaire mais moi vous
ne m'entendrez pas accuser le
gouvernement alors je suis en opposition
par rapport à la politique qu'il mène
vous ne vous ne m'entendrez pas l'accusé
par rapport à des décisions qui sont
prises et qui correspondent à la
connaissance qu'on a de l'épidémie au
moment où la décision est prise je ne le
fais pas parce que effectivement je
considère que petit à petit on a une
meilleure connaissance de la pandémie et
donc et bien on se pose d'autres
questions
il ya quelques mois en arrière on
pensait que les enfants ne pouvait pas
transmettre la maladie maintenant on est
beaucoup plus prudent donc je ne vais
pas faire des procès d'intention de cet
ordre là ce que je dis et c'est pour ça
que je m'insurge contre les décisions
qui sont prises c'est qu'il n'ya pas
absolument on a l'impression qu'il ya
jamais de plan b et que le gouvernement
agit le dos au mur chaque fois c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui par exemple les
enseignants nous alerte en nous disant
que si jamais il y avait confinement eh
bien ils ne sont pas en capacité de
pouvoir à distance assurer
l'enseignement à leurs élèves c'est sa
plume line sérieux
on a déjà vu on a déjà analysé ces
difficultés là aujourd'hui on sait qu'il
faut prioriser
il ya des personnes qui ne vont pas
pouvoir télétravailler et bien notamment
les enseignants c'est compliqué mais
tout seul et premier de corvée les
éboueurs les caissières
les personnels soignants les personnels
du médico social etc
cela ne peuvent pas télétravail et donc
quelles mesures on prend pourraient
vacciner tout de suite pour laisser la
pala par exemple et pour ce qu'ils sont
et pour ceux qui sont en télétravail
qu'est-ce qu'on organise par rapport au
télétravail pour assurer que ça se passe
dans de bonnes conditions parce que les
on voit qu'il ya une baisse par exemple
du télétravail
entre décembre et aujourd'hui février
s'est passée de 44% à 31 % et on sait en
même temps qu'à une productivité des
salariés plus importante de l'ordre de
22%
mais il faut protéger il faut avoir le
droit à la déconnexion il faut réduire
le temps de travail 32 heures autant de
mesures qu'il faut prendre
est ce qu'on entend le gouvernement là
dessus non à chaque fois il attend au
dernier moment et il s'enferme dans sa
tour d'ivoire au lieu d'être en
concertation et travailler en
collaboration avec tout le monde
elle est on va rejoindre à présent notre
streamer politique jean massiet sur
tweets champ où tu échanges avec ta
communauté depuis trois quarts d'heure
maintenant même un petit peu plus
je suppose que les annonces des manuels
macron qu'on attend à 20h sur dans
toutes les têtes il ya beaucoup de
questions là dessus mais oui tu aimes tu
t'en doutes évidemment beaucoup de
questions de la part des internautes qui
veulent savoir à quelle sauce on va être
mangé mais surtout en fait la question
qu'il se pose c'est une question de
stratégie de critères quels sont les
critères sur lesquels on pourra sortir
de cette crise du coc vide on se
souvient qu'en décembre dernier emmanuel
macron avait parlé de cinq mille
nouveaux cas par jour c'était le cap
qu'il avait fixés kim qui n'a
malheureusement jamais été atteint mais
du coup les internautes sont nombreux à
se poser des questions sur tout
simplement on veut de la visibilité et
c'est ça qui attendent le plus les
internautes
on espère que peut-être le gouvernement
cet après-midi devant les sénateurs et
sénatrices pourra apporter quelques
éléments de réponse sur ce point là il
ya un autre sujet qui t'en doutes qui tu
t'en doutes qui a qui inquiète les
internautes soient plutôt qu'ils les
questionne c'est la fermeture des écoles
je leur ai demandé s'ils étaient
favorables ou pas la fermeture des
écoles pour faire face au co vide face
aux taux d'incidence qui augmente aux
contaminations à l'école
problèmes dénoncés par les enseignants
et à 62% ils répondent oui oui oui il
souhaite la fermeture des écoles il
verrait ça comme une bonne décision
c'est emmanuel macron annoncé ça tout à
l'heure donc on verra
dernier sujet les internautes aimeraient
bien voir a donc évoqué dans l'hémicycle
cet après midi par les sénateurs et
sénatrices c'est le bombardement au mali
les nations unies les experts des
nations unies ont pointé la
responsabilité de la france dans un
bombardement en janvier dernier qui a
fait des morts civils les internautes
aimeraient bien que le gouvernement soit
mis face à cette responsabilité et s'en
explique
voilà les sujets qui sont attendus cet
après-midi à damas merci merci beaucoup
juin beaucoup de co vide mais pas
seulement et notamment la question de ce
bombardement au mali au mois de janvier
2020 je voudrais juste vous posez une
autre une autre question françois
patriat sûr quand même quelque chose qui
est un petit peu connexes et la tenue
des régionales on voit que c'est qu'elle
joue dans beaucoup beaucoup de têtes est
ce que vous êtes personnellement
aujourd'hui pourront contre le report
des régionales il y avait les arguments
pour les arguments contre et on a quinze
jours pour décider les arguments pour
c'est de dire effectivement au mois de
septembre on aura 30 40 millions de
personnes vaccinées
effectivement s'il a fait ce métier on
pourra faire campagne
tant que c'est un argument plus qu'à
attendre qu'ils étendent abl dans le
même temps je crois que les gens
l'opposition veut dire mais on peut
travailler on peut aller à l'école on
peut aller dehors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
peut pas voter faut que la démocratie
aujourd'hui et le sentiment de dire que
le gouvernement ne voudrait pas que les
élections ont lieu maintenant parce
qu'il l'aurait peur de les perdre
politique tout c'est totalement faux moi
je pense que si on peut faire les
élections il faut lui faire si on peut
le faire il faut jouer ces scientifiques
dans l'une d'une ambiguïté terrible
voilà abeilles tranche pas le conseil
scientifique laurence cohen moi je
voudrais quand même dire trois choses
d'abord un c'est qu'il ya une sacrée
hypocrisie parce que quand les gens à
juste titre demande quels sont les
critères par rapport aux décisions
politiques qui sont pris sur le coco
vide les critères ça a été dit par le
gouvernement c'est un une absence de
capacité hospitalière et c'est ça qui
les guide donc il faut changer de
politique hospitalière
quand on nous dit c'est pareil dans le
monde et en europe c'est le même système
de restriction des budgets de la santé
et c'est celui-là qui cette politique
l'alcool
dix neuf mille habitants je vous dis à
dire des comptes revient sur rue à des
contrevérités regarder tous les budgets
de la sécurité sociale qui ont été volés
ils sont tous ce sont tous des budgets
osterrieth airs que vous avez voté que
je n'ai pas voté donc sur les élections
aura fait sur les élections locales
étaient rapidement moi je pense qu'il
faut garantir la démocratie pour
garantir la démocratie il faut
évidemment préserver la santé de nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyennes
mais il faut permettre le débat
démocratique alors si ce sont des
élections où finalement il ne peut pas y
avoir de campagne de contact avec les
gens de mobilisation dans les quartiers
sur le quotidien des gens
et bien à ce moment là ça n'est pas une
vraie consultation pour les régionales
et pour les cantonales c'est tout ça
qu'il faut gardons pas on ne peut pas
non plus se projeter à l'état de la
france
en juin c'était un petit peu compliqué
au moment où on se parle
alors il faut laisser les choses ouverte
à arriver un dans la salle des
conférences marlène schiappa marlène
schiappa qui devrait qui devait dans les
prochains jours venir faire une
information parlementaire autour du
rapport du conseil scientifique tout de
suite on va continuer dans les réactions
celle des comptes et on va aller voir
alexandre pousse à vous êtes avec
guillaume gontard président du groupe
écologiste au sénat on va parler une
autre actualité celle du sénat dans
l'hémicycle au tour et bien du projet de
la séparatisme mais aussi du coc vide
oui on va d'abord parlé qu'aux vide qui
augmente art qu'est ce que vous attendez
de l'allocution du président de la
république ce soir ce que vous attendez
1re confinement nationale je pense qu'en
tout cas il ya nécessité d'agir moi ça
me questionne juste sur encore une fois
sur la méthode puisque tout le monde va
être suspendue aux lèvres d'un seul
homme ce soir à 20 heures qu'on aura un
débat nous parlementaires uniquement
uniquement demain donc après coup donc
c'est vrai que ça pose quand même des
questions sur le fonctionnement de
nos institutions il me semble que oui a
nécessité d'agir on voit bien que ce que
la situation se dégrader dans plusieurs
départements
je vois sur mon département de l'isère
la situation est particulièrement
dramatique aujourd'hui
donc oui je pense on a perdu du temps je
pense qu il falloir confiné je pense
qu'on aurait pu être encore une fois
beaucoup plus associés on a les vacances
de pâques qui arrive je pense qu'il faut
peut-être se caler sur ces vacances de
pâques et notamment réfléchir sur la
fermeture des écoles pendant cette
période on l'avait proposé en q âgées la
semaine dernière j'espère que ce sont
des choses qui vont être nu mais encore
une fois on attend la parole
présidentielle
voilà donc pour vous la fermeture des
écoles pendant les prochaines vacances
est une solution
alors je voudrais qu'on parle d'un autre
sujet du projet loi séparatisme le débat
a commencé hier au sénat il a commencé
très fort puisque le sénat a interdit le
port de signes religieux et notamment du
voile pour les accompagnants de sorties
scolaires pour les mineurs les sénateurs
ont également permis l'interdiction du
burkina dans les piscines
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce vote de
la majorité droite et du centre
d'abord c'est un texte qui qui qui
abîment nos principes nos principes
républicains à la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité sur ces trois domaines à
chaque fois on est en constant en
constant recul
donc c'est particulièrement inquiétant
et moi j'ai été particulièrement peiné
par les débats d'hier soir on a passé
trois heures 6 heures sur la police de
l'habillement savoir si on devait ou non
mettre un burqini ou ou un maillot de
bain couvrant pour aller pour aller à la
piscine je me sens je pense quand même
que aujourd'hui on attend à d'autres
priorités et qu'ici à la séparatiste est
un séparatisme social qu'on est dans un
pays où on a dépassé les 10 millions de
pauvres et c'est peut-être sur cette
question là qu'il faut vraiment
travailler
qu'est ce que vous pensez du procès qui
est fait un peu en ce moment aux
écologistes notamment sur la question de
l'islamisme radical et d'une certaine
complaisance qu'est ce que vous répondez
à toutes ces critiques dans le débat
actuel
bah je réponds qu'ils s'attaquent aux
valeurs de la république aujourd'hui est
ce que ce sont les écologistes
moi il me semble pas il me semble quand
on va sur les sur les frontières franco
italienne et qu'on défend l'humanité
cédric airs ou d'ailleurs qui après x
procès
a été voilà était en train de dire été
graciées nous on défend par tous ces
valeurs républicaines de la liberté de
l'égalité de la fraternité dont les
discours que j'ai entendu hier que j'ai
entendu adroitement particulièrement
choqué parce que c d e c'est aller
contre les lois de 1905 qui sont le
socle de notre république
donc il sait qu'ils s'attaquent à la
république c'est pas nous merci beaucoup
pour votre réaction
il ya une guitare président du groupe
écologiste au sénat merci beaucoup
alexandre françois patriat en un mot le
sujet le voile c'est un vrai sujet ou
est-ce que ça vous paraît décalé
aujourd'hui dans le contexte comme le
disait guillaume gontard autour et bien
de ce projet de loi sur les principes de
la bresle je suis avec d'accord avec
bogota c'est la deuxième partie mais
qu'il dit aujourd'hui un débat inutile
un voulait éviter le débat du voile le
sénat nous l'a imposée par contre quand
il dit que cette loi est une loi
liberticide côté si le second tard ne
voit pas que dans notre pays il ya du
communautarisme il ya l'islamisme
radical
il ya des attentats qu'on peut pas y
remédier là c'est une sorte d'
aveuglement je ne comprends pas laurence
cohen va très vite moi j'ai été très
choqué par le débat qu'il y a eu sur le
voile ou finalement la majorité on était
d'accord et d'ailleurs je le dis
d'accord avec le ministre norman lamont
a donc parce que c'était un débat qui a
stigmatisé les mamans qui portent le
voile et qui accompagnent leurs enfants
à l'école ou en sortie surtout en sortie
et ça vraiment c'est quelque chose de
très grave effectivement pour notre
république c'est à dire que l'école va
trier les parents qui vont pouvoir
accompagner les enfants en sortie
scolaire c'est un homme un amalgame
entre finalement la religion telle
qu'elle peut être pratiqué pensée et
cetera
et puis effectivement un islamisme
radical tout est confus et c'est très
très graves pour notre pour notre
démocratie pour notre république et ce
débat n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu
tequila eu lieu dans l'hémicycle on a
vraiment entendu des des choses très
très réactionnaire hier françois patriat
bruno retailleau va tenir un point
presse à 16h30 autour de ce sujet autour
du burkina autour du voile pour
emine pour les accompagnantes de sorties
scolaires qu'est ce que ça vous laisse
comme sentiment est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils adressent un message
politique à travers cette interprétation
et ses modifications qui sont apportées
au texte du gouvernement en doutiez
c'est mal connaître bruno retailleau il
adresse toujours des messages très
politiques et des messages enfin
consensus dans la matière je veux dire
lié aussi à la campagne ou à la halle un
temps démentiel et c'était bien pas
aujourd'hui de prises politique ne soit
pas lui qui n'intègre pas une arrière
pensée électorale voir présidentielle je
pense que je pense que le sénat s'est
pas bien conduit hier soir dans ce débat
tout à fait je pense qu'on est passé à
côté du vrai débat des vraies questions
là dessus guillaume gothard 11 cohen ont
raison le premier le ministre de l' été
parfait dans ses réponses en disant
aujourd'hui les leçons des libertés
laissons jeudi l'authenticité aux gens
n'allons pas dans la halle team des
familles je crois que c'était à ce
réputé être un débat posé il a été il a
été un peu hystériser et je regrette
mais cette hystérisation comme il fait
comme les syriens d'être soulignée elle
est due au fait qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement le gouvernement
d'emmanuel macron prend des mesures qui
sont des mesures liberticides et chacun
veut donner des gages à l'extrême droite
et donc effectivement abîme blesse les
nos principes républicains juste
intégralité devait cela qui fait ce
délibéré 6,6 ce texte n'est pas un bon
texte ça c'est autre chose nous ne
serons pas d'accord mais sur les mesures
libérales a envoyé en plus la droite
renchérit et à g avec effectivement des
des amendements qui ne se trouvaient pas
dans la loi si elle le voile ne se
trouvait pas dans la loi un texte du
gouvernement et équilibrée une
divergence divergences et une surenchère
sur votre propre taxe estime laurence
cohen et vous êtes aussi responsable de
ces textes et madame cohen vous échappe
pas que je soutiens le texte du
gouvernement quel qu'il est issu de
l'assemblée qui est équilibré qui prend
des mesures
aujourd'hui contre contre les jeunes
filles contre les femmes quand on voit
des rats qui prend des mesures contre le
communautarisme et qui le font parce que
c'est un rien de problème
l'appel comme une odeur existe dans ce
pays il faut le dire il faut lutter
contre bien écouter merci beaucoup pour
ce débat tout de suite et bien on a un
marché qui sort du cabinet de départ on
va rejoindre steve jourdain dans
l'hémicycle et pour parler un petit peu
bien de ce dont on va parler lors de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
au 8ème à l'aura compris aux séances
actualiser un peu particulière cet après
midi emmanuel macron doit donc parler ce
soir 20 heures il le parlement est
suspendu aux lèvres du chef de l'état
mais show must go on les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement vont débuter
il vient dans quelques instants
maintenant au menu du jour notamment
l'avenir des écoles de france ouvertes
fermées faut rappeler la règle
actuellement un seul cas de co vite dans
une classe et c'est toute la classe qui
doit fermer ça c'est pour les régions
les plus touchées les plus concernés par
l'épidémie mais les élus considèrent que
cette règle est actuellement
insuffisante les experts considèrent
certains experts considèrent que les
lieux sont des jeux des lieux majeurs de
contamination que faut-il faire sur sur
ce sujet comme sur d'autres emmanuel
macron et bien devra trancher
il prendra la parole ce soir 20 heures
en attendant les sénateurs vont
interpeller le gouvernement pour essayer
de glaner notamment des informations
auprès du gouvernement la séance a
débuté on en reparle juste après pour le
débrief
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues par lettre en date de ce jour
monsieur le premier ministre a informé
que le gouvernement fera une déclaration
en application de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution relatives à l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire et aux mesures
nécessaires pour y répondre
suivie d'un débat et d'un vote demain à
15h acte est donc donnée de cette
demande en conséquence le gouvernement
de vente que le sénat siège
ce vendredi 2 avril matin après midi et
soir pour poursuivre l'examen du projet
de loi comportant le respect du principe
de la république par ailleurs par lettre
en date de ce jour le gouvernement
demande d'inscription à l'ordre du jour
du mercredi 7 avril après-midi après les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur la proposition de loi pour
une sécurité globale préservant les
libertés acte est donnée de ces demandes
nous prévient on pourrions prévoir
d'ailleurs pour ce texte une discussion
générale de 45 minutes
c'est à dire des observations
vous me donnez avant la fin de la séance
si on n'a pas une en état c'est décidé
je me tourne vers les président e vo je
les vois dans la joie et donc les voyant
dans la joie je considère qu'il en est
ainsi décidé l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
sur notre site internet
chacun chacun sera tant utile ailleurs
tout au long du déroulement de notre
avancée ans et en dehors de cet
hémicycle à respecter les consignes
sanitaires qui sont données et à
observer le respect du temps et des uns
et les autres je donne la parole à notre
collègue bernard jomier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres lors du choix entre les
patients est arrivé dans les premiers
hôpitaux
je ne citerai que les propos du chef du
service de réanimation du chu nancy qui
hier annoncé plusieurs décès dans son
service lié à des déprogrammations
d'intervention le tri va s'accélérer et
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
récente de notre pays
ce n'est pas la conséquence d'un
événement imprévu
c'est la conséquence du choix d'un homme
qui dans une volonté de concentration à
l'excès de ses prérogatives
constitutionnelles a pris cette décision
c'est de chef de l'état votre
gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre applique cette décision en
laissant circuler le virus à un niveau
élevé depuis deux mois
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
exprimer des regrets des remords des
excuses vis-à-vis des français de leurs
proches qui sont victimes de cette
obstination pour vous répondre
la parole le corps
la ministre déléguée en charge de
l'autonomie madame brigitte bourguignon
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur bernard
jomier permettez moi tout d'abord de
vous dire que il n'ya pas de tri et que
ce mot devrait être bannie de notre
vocabulaire
à ce stade de la crise sanitaire la
crise sanitaire mondiale que nous
traversons nous mobilise maintenant
depuis un an et demi dans notre pays
comme ailleurs d'ailleurs nous avons eu
à développer des réponses mesure et
évolutive
face à la situation que nous connaissons
mais nous avons aussi un devoir de
transparence auprès des français la
réalité monsieur le sénateur c'est que
la mobilisation des français leur
résilience l'action publique mobilisée
nous permettent d'entrevoir le bout du
tunnel
comme dans les ehpad où la vaccination
ouvrent le chemin des retrouvailles
la réalité c'est aussi le fait que la
situation sanitaire demeure plus que
préoccupante
plus de 29 mille français sont
hospitalisés en raison du coc vide et
que les patients atteints du virus
occupe 89 % des lits de réanimation
malgré toute notre action comme celle
des autres pays pour repousser les murs
de nos hôpitaux
pour y faire face nous sommes dans
l'action sans relâche cette action vous
la connaissez une gestion quotidienne de
l'ensemble des ressources dont nous
disposons
au regard de l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire concrètement c'est permettre
de déployer des outils masque gel
vaccins dont nous avons besoin s'assurer
qu'ils aillent où il faut quand il faut
grâce à une logistique d'ampleur c'est
aussi une réponse territorialisée
concertée en fonction des situations
vécues dans chaque région
nous rendons compte en toute
transparence en temps réel chaque
semaine nous échangeons dans ce même
hémicycle
quand la situation l'exigé monsieur le
président de la république s'adresse à
nos concitoyens ce qu'il entend faire ce
soir
vous comprendrez qu'il ne m'appartient
pas de préjuger de ses propos néanmoins
en complément des temps dédié le premier
ministre a fait le choix d'ouvrir un
débat parlementaire dès demain pour que
nous puissions échanger plus largement
en toute transparence sur la réponse la
plus adaptée à la situation que nous
connaissons
monsieur le sénateur les français
attendent mieux que de vaines polémiques
ils sont nous à la hauteur de l'enjeu
pour sortir collectivement plus fort de
cette crise la pomme suis jolie madame
la ministre vous pouvez vouloir bannir
un mot du vocabulaire vous ne le bannir
et pas de la réalité et canton des
programmes plus de 80 % des
interventions dans les hôpitaux à quoi
qu'on craignez vous les soignants si ce
n'est à choisir à quoi les contraignez
vous si ce n'est de prendre certains
patients et de ne pas en prendre
d'autres et ce qui m'inquiète voyez vous
dans vos propos c'est ce déni persistant
de la réalité il a ce déni persistant de
la réalité vous ajoutez une gestion de
la crise par un homme seul futile chef
de l'état qui encore une fois ne
consultera pas le parlement après ces
décisions mais viendra comme dans une
chambre d'enregistrement et c'est
scandaleux
[Applaudissements]
la parole comme leurs collègues
pour nouveau jeu rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président mais se
prémunissant mes chers collègues nous
savons que la troisième vague est très
grave et sommes une nouvelle fois en
élus responsables aux côtés de nous tous
nos soignants soucieux de continuer les
gestes barrière mais la situation d'un
sanitaire n'interdit pas d'envisager
l'avenir
mes proches ni même de faire des projets
collectifs comme celui des prochaines
élections
depuis plus d'un an les élus et
candidats aux élections départementales
et régionales vont comme ulysse de
report en report de faux départ en faux
espoirs ils ne sont pas à ce titre
pellemans mobilisables pour la durée sur
la durée pour appuyer les plans de
relance être à côté de celles et ceux
qui vivent la crise sanitaire et sociale
que nous traversons les exécutifs
attendent
lundi le conseil scientifique comme la
loi du 23 février 2021 le prévoit a émis
un avis concernant un possible nouveau
report des élections départementales et
régionales dont nous venons pourtant
d'adopter le report en juin les élus mes
chers collègues encore l'amertume des
conditions de préparation si incertaine
des élections municipales de mars 2020
nous ne pourrons pas forcément à
réitérer l'exploit aujourd'hui comme
n'hésitez pas à le dire françois
mitterrand l'action politique à
certaines heures et comme le scalpel du
chirurgien elle ne laisse pas de la
place à l'incertitude
aussi monsieur le premier ministre nous
vous demandons nous nous proposer très
vite une date fixe un projet de loi un
calendrier un débat parlementaire
ainsi qu'une population rapide nous
souhaitons chers collègues sacraliser le
moment de la campagne électorale de la
confrontation des projets le sel de
notre démocratie tout en assurant la
sécurisation sanitaire juridique des
candidats et électeurs et personnel pour
le moment et le campagne électorale sans
contact ce n'est pas ce qui se fait de
mieux
nous demandons également de prévoir dès
à présent des conditions de vous adapter
à toutes situations de crise mes chers
collègues les élus départementaux et
régionaux sont indispensables pour
affronter ensemble et rapidement les ou
en très difficiles qui s'annoncent aussi
monsieur le premier ministre
dedans avait limiers certes saurons nous
enjoint de citoyens pour vous répondre
paroles et à la milice délégué en charge
de la citoyenneté madame marlène
schiappa vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices mais sur les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean yves roux le
conseil scientifique vous l'avez rappelé
a reçu mandat d'émettre un avis sur le
déroulement du scrutin démocratique en
période d'épidémie
il a mené un travail difficile et
remarquable et je veux ici le saluer et
ce malgré les différentes incertitude
persistante quant à l'évolution de la
crise sanitaire
ce rapport il était prévu dans la loi
que nous avons ensemble débattu et que
vous avez voté sur le report des
élections régionales
ces élections vous l'avez dit elles sont
un moment démocratique fondamentale de
notre pays le moment où chacun peut
exercer son droit dirais-je son devoir
de citoyen et venir voter c'est un temps
d'expression fondamental pour notre
démocratie et après un an de crise
sanitaire nous contre eux nous
évidemment la laisse site ud et même
parfois l'incompréhension des français
vis-à-vis de ces questions la
responsabilité du gouvernement c'est de
prendre des décisions souvent difficile
mais toujours nécessaire pour la santé
des français le report ou le maintien
des élections c'est une décision qui est
lourde de conséquences je veux vous le
dire le premier ministre jean castex va
lancer des consultations afin d'aboutir
à une solution qui soit compatible avec
la protection de chacun contre
l'épidémie mais aussi avec les
impératifs démocratique et nous
chercherons pour cela le consensus
politique le plus large possible avec
l'ensemble des partis et des groupes
représentés d'ailleurs le gouvernement
sera dès demain présent à l'appel du
parlement en séance publique pour un
débat sur ce sujet en la matière et en
tout état de cause le parlement exerce
et exercera son rôle pleinement
quelle que soit la solution retenue
après les consultations et après je
souhaite l'obtention de ce consensus le
gouvernement mettra tout en oeuvre pour
assurer à la fois la sécurité sanitaire
mais aussi la sincérité de ce scrutin
ce qui est fondamental et vous êtes
nombreux à l'avoir appelée au cours de
nos débats et ce débat aura lieu comme
il a eu lieu pour le report des
élections en juin pour le deuxième tour
des élections municipales je vous
remercie
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
guillaume gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
lundi le fabricant de silicium ferro
peine annoncé la suppression de 360
emplois en savoie et en isère
c'est à savoir faire centenaire qui est
menacée
le silicium est un produit essentiel
pour de nombreuses activités
industrielles et notamment la
fabrication de panneaux photovoltaïques
en isère toujours c'est l'entreprise
photowatt l'un des rares producteurs
français de panneaux solaires ces 215
salariés leur immense savoir-faire qui
sont également menacés après avoir
acheté ces panneaux solaires en chine
pendant des années sa maison mère edf se
désengage on marche totalement sur la
tête sur l'autel de la rentabilité
capitaliste c'est toute la filière
photovoltaïque française voire
européenne qui est sacrifiée l'énergie
solaire est pourtant indispensable tant
pour la transition énergétique pour la
souveraineté de la france ne plus
produire de panneaux photovoltaïques en
france s'est aggravé notre bilan carbone
et d'autres dépendances à la chine
un comble en pleine loi climat ceci
témoigne de l'absence totale de
stratégie en matière de transition
énergétique de la france
l'ombre colossal des reculs plane sur
cette triste affaire
pendant qu'on s'apprête à nationaliser à
financer à fonds perdus la filière
nucléaire qui ne sera jamais rentable
on continue toujours de confier au privé
tout l'effort de transition énergétique
sacrée réussite
nous sommes déjà en retard sur les
objectifs 2020 alors monsieur le premier
ministre
trois questions allez-vous agir pour
sauver le panneau solaire français allez
vous enfin déployer une stratégie
publique de développement des énergies
renouvelables et respecter les objectifs
de votre ppe
allez-vous consulter le parlement et le
peuple avant d'engager avec le projet
hercules l'avenir énergétique de la
france pour les 30 prochaines années
un pont de la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président merci
pour votre question qui me donne
l'occasion de m'exprimer sur un sujet
majeur qui est celui de la production
d'électricité photovoltaïque et ses
conséquences industrielles pour notre
pays pour l'europe vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président nous avons des
ambitions fortes qui sont décrites dans
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie qui a été adopté dans le cadre
de la loi climat le 21 avril 2020 par
décret et que nous essayons de mettre en
oeuvre l'origine de l'électricité
produit par photovoltaïque progresse
sans cesse
année après année un rythme soutenu et
nous devons continuer à inviter votre
question on le sait renvoie un autre
sujet qui est celui de l'origine les
panneaux des tuiles et des cellules
photovoltaïques dont tu es originaire
cette électricité qui nous le savons
vous le savez vous l'avez rappelé sans
depuis très longtemps d'origine importés
et en particulier disons le carrément de
très loin plutôt d'extrême orient avec
un bilan carbone extrêmement défavorable
nous devons changer cela vous vous
souvenez que pour encourager la
consommation d'électricité d'origine
photovoltaïque
nous avions plusieurs gouvernements
successifs augmenter les tarifs d'achat
que nous avons été ensuite plusieurs
gouvernements successifs obligé de
relever c'est précisément parce que cela
faisait surtout la sphère de producteurs
étrangers
cela suppose donc une vraie stratégie
industrielle
et c'est là que je me démarquerait des
observations que vous avez fait car
cette stratégie industrielle qui a
longtemps manqué tient longtemps manqué
nous la mettons progressivement en place
d'abord d'abord en veillant à ce que les
appels d'offres
tous les appels d'offres pour l'achat de
ces matériels comporte des critères en
matière de contenu carbone afin de
favoriser les panneaux les plus
performants c'est à dire produit avec
l'impact climatique le plus réduit vous
le savez sur présent ce qui conduira
écarté un certain nombre de ces produits
importés car ne répondant pas à ces
conditions
ensuite cette stratégie industrielle il
faut la faire aussi je le dis dans un
cadre européen et nous travaillons avec
la commission sur la possibilité
d'introduire des critères de contenu de
production locale dans tous les appels
d'offres pour le solaire qui sont
conduits à l'échelle du territoire
communautaire nous sommes égales prime
également positionné comme un état
moteur je parle de la france pour le
lancement d'une alliance européenne pour
le photovoltaïque quatre exactement dans
les objectifs que vous avez appelez de
vos voeux alliance européenne qui a été
annoncé par la ministre en charge de
l'industrie
le 22 février dernier aux côtés du
commissaire chargé de l'énergie
enfin la france elle même mais des
moyens dans la capacité de développer et
de promouvoir cette filière il ya
beaucoup de pme de tei que nous
soutenons je pense au projet accueil au
projet bene l'os au projet photo hâte
que nous avons sauvé que nous avons
sauvé lorsque j'ai pris mes fonctions de
chef du gouvernement
vous avez raison de le rappeler edf
voulait fermer photowatt
nous l'avons empêcher je le dis devant
le sénat nous l'avons empêcher et photos
à de vie toujours nous allons soutenir
le projet re c'est cela à sarreguemines
pour lequel le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisée et qui va demander
beaucoup d'argent public
bref mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous sommes le gouvernement ce
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour la construction d'une filière
photovoltaïque souveraine et durable
monsieur le président vos torts merci
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
mais vous n'avez pas répondu notamment
sur sur hercules et sur la place d'edf
effectivement en 2012 oui edf a repris
photowatt est ce que là aujourd'hui vous
allez faire pression sur edf pour qu'il
conserve cette filiale à 100% et qu'il
achète ces panneaux chez photowatt est
là dessus vous ne valez pas répondu non
la parole maintenant notre collègue
pierre jean verzeaux laine pour le
groupe les indépendants merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse au
ministre des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre les quelques 35
mille maires de france viennent de
recevoir comme chaque année l'état 12 59
le fameux la version 2021 est marqué par
la réforme de la fiscalité locale
d'une part la fin de l'encaissement de
la taxe d'habitation par les communes
d'autre part le transfert aux communes
de la part départementale du taux de
foncier bâti
comme de nombreux collègues j'ai été
sollicité ces derniers jours par les
maires suite à la réception de cet état
12 59 et notamment à propos du savant
calcul du coefficient correcteur qui je
cite est égal à 1 plus la ressource à
compenser - la ressource de compensation
cette somme elle même divisée par la
taxe foncière sur les propriétés bâties
après cette réforme
je m'arrête là
[Applaudissements]
ce document est un véritable
chef-d'oeuvre de l'administration
fiscale aussi compliqué à comprendre
qu'une attestation dérogatoire vous le
savez cette réforme suscite chez
nombreux élus des inquiétudes sur la
compensation de la taxe d'habitation
c'est pourquoi un effort de
clarification est nécessaire sur la
détermination du coefficient correcteur
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
doit prévoir un exercice de
simplification et d'explication à
destination des mères j'ajoute en fin
d'année les français vont recevoir leur
feuille d'impôts locaux et pour 80 pour
ce 80 % d'entre eux la taxe d'habitation
va disparaître il restera le foncier
bâti qui figurera sur une seule ligne
avec un seul taux qui sera l'addition du
taux communal et du taux départemental
les maires comme toujours seront
directement responsable devant les
habitants par souci de transparence il
est indispensable qu'une clarifications
soient faites auprès du contribuable
afin qu'il n'ait pas l'impression que la
commune est augmenté massivement taux de
foncier
en contrepartie de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation décidés par l'état
merci monsieur le ministre de nous
apporter vos précisions à la matière on
vous répandre la parole les communistes
délégué chargé des comptes publics
monsieur olivier du shop
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vers 2 m quelques mots pour
répondre à votre question est d'abord
vous rassurer l'état 12 59 que vous avez
évoqué n'a pas changé fondamentalement
par rapport à l'année dernière
il porte toujours pour les communes les
informations les plus précises possibles
sur les recettes prévisionnelles en
matière de fiscalité pour leur permettre
de bâtir leur budget la direction
générale des finances publiques est
totalement mobilisée notamment pour
répondre à la crise mais à veiller à
dresser cet état avant le 31 mars comme
le prévoit le règlement
et si d'aventuré une commune recevait
cet état plus tard elles bénéficient
automatiquement de 15 jours
supplémentaires pour tenir compte de ce
délai dans l'approbation de son budget
quelle est la principale différence la
différence tient la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation
cela passe par deux canaux le calcul du
coefficient correcteur vous avez rappelé
sa formule telle qu'elle est
littéralement expliqué il s'agit en
réalité d'une règle de trois lorsque les
ressources attribuées depuis le
département sont hélas on est que la
ressource précédente de la collectivité
était égal à 80 c 08
mais on peut aussi le rédigé de manière
littérale comme vous avez cieux le
rappeler nous avions transmis à
l'ensemble des communes l'intégralité
des simulations l'année dernière et nous
avons demandé aux directions
départementale des finances publiques de
rééditer un exercice de pédagogie
d'explication auprès de chaque maire
pour expliquer quelles sont les
différences concernant la taxe foncière
il ya effectivement addition des taux
comme nous l'avions annoncé mais le
montant total de la taxe foncière sur
les propriétés bâties reste strictement
le même
nonobstant d'éventuelles évolutions de
taux décidées par telle ou telle
collectivité désormais l'attributaire
cette taxe mais à taux constants cela
reste le même montant payé par le
contribuable
enfin troisième point que je veux
souligner en réponse à votre question
pour peut-être corriger une très légère
imprécision dans votre propos vous avez
indiqué qu'en septembre prochain les
comptes 80 % des contribuables recevront
une fiche d'impôts locaux avec une taxe
d'habitation disparu en réalité c'est en
septembre dernier que 80 % des français
ont vu disparaître sa taxe d'habitation
et en septembre prochain et 20% de
français de ménages continuant à payer
cette taxe d'habitation verront la
première baisse d'un tiers
il y a toujours deux feuilles
d'imposition locale une pour feu la taxe
d'habitation une taxe foncière il n'y
aura donc pas de compte de confusion
mais je le répète
l'ensemble des maires recevront une
explication plus détaillée peut-être
plus littéraire de l'état de 59 qu'ils
ont réussi récemment
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue vincent segouin pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je viens d'avoir 32 ans
et je me suis fait vacciner
la logique aurait voulu que mes parents
le soir avant moi mais ils n'ont pas la
chance de vivre aux états unis
tels sont les messages que nous recevons
voici monsieur le premier ministre
comment et vu la france cinquième
puissance mondiale depuis un an nous
vivons rip déconfinement déconfinement
de la fermeture des écoles et des
commerces et du triste décompte des
réanimations et des morts un an plus
tard nous avons le sentiment que rien
n'a changé
rien n'a évolué et que malgré votre
assurance et votre volonté de tout faire
seul sans concertation vous n'avaient
tiré aucun enseignement de vos erreurs
l'année dernière vous nous premier tier
14500 lits de réanimation
la vérité est qu'il n'y en a que 6733
lie l'association public privé ne se
fait toujours pas un an plus tard de la
solution vaccinale existe mais en france
seule 3,9 pour cent de la population est
vaccinée alors qu'elle est de 50% aux
etats-unis 60% en grande bretagne et
même 85% d'israël si nous nous comparons
à d'autres pays ce que vous aimez faire
quand cela vous est flatteur nous voyons
que nous pouvons mieux faire
alors une question monsieur le premier
ministre pendant combien de temps
allez-vous nous faire vivre au rythme de
ces annonces toujours plus pessimistes
les unes que les autres pour répondre la
parole est à la ministre déléguée en
charge l'autonomie mana bourguignon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vincent segouin puisque vous
commencez en parlant des états unis
permettez moi de ne pas rappeler le
nombre de morts qu'il ya eu dans ce pays
que d'autres tout le monde parlait
récemment vous rappeler aussi que la
moitié des élèves ce qui représente 55
millions d'enfants n'ont pas eu de cours
depuis un an et que je pense que nous
avons préservé de ce danger nos élèves
en france et pis permettez moi de vous
dire aussi parce que j'ai entendu
quelque chose de blessant qu'ici
personne n'est insensible aux victimes
du coc vide
quel que soit son statut que nous soyons
ministres députés nous avons des
familles et nous avons parfois des
drames personnels
voilà donc face à cette urgence il nous
a fallu nous adapter
évaluer et puis évoluer les protocoles
les doctrines parfois en poussant les
murs parfois en transformant les
industries pour créer
masque du gel hydroalcoolique maintenant
des vaccins avec une logistique
considérable
enfin il nous a fallu à girac méthodes
et avec transparence
cela nous a permis d'avoir des résultats
que nul ne croyait possible
il y a encore quelques semaines
concrètement plus de 8,2 millions de
personnes ont bénéficié d'au moins une
injection et 2,8 au moins deux peut-être
pourrions-nous nous féliciter ensemble
du 92 % des résidents en ehpad ont reçu
au moins une dose et plus de la moitié
des personnes de plus de 75 ans ont
également été vaccinées je pense que
c'est un effort collectif dont nous nous
devrions nous réjouir et qui nous
placent en tête des pays européens sur
la vaccination des personnes les plus
âgées c'est un tour de force qui a été
rendue possible par la mobilisation de
tous les acteurs
les acteurs et l'accélération de notre
campagne vaccinale
concrètement sur la seule semaine
dernière 1 8 millions d'injections été
faites qui représente un sur trois
vaccins atteint astrazeneca ce n'a pas
été possible parce que nous avons
favorisé la confiance nous avons
vraiment misé sur la confiance nous
accélérons la campagne est notre
objectif sera tenu de 10 millions mi
avril en priorisant les publics les plus
fragiles les plus exposés en
démultipliant les canaux avec
l'ouverture de méga centres dédiés avec
le concours des forces armées en monte
en puissance et que les centres de
vaccination existant sur les territoires
caucourt mobilisant tous les
professionnels de santé possible et en
allant vers les personnes les plus
isolées
merci monsieur chez moi je lisais
récemment que l'union européenne a été
soucieuse de négocier des vaccins au
meilleur prix et avec le meilleur
encadrement juridique
la vérité est donc là notre problème
monsieur le premier ministre et que la
france est géré par la peur et la
division parce que vous avez vous même
peur de prendre des risques
avouez que vous avez attendu de voir le
résultat des campagnes de vaccination
dans les pays hors union européenne pour
juger des effets secondaires et pour
enfin commandés et organiser des
vaccinations aujourd'hui vous nous
annoncez que vous allez mettre en place
des vaccinodromes alors que nos
professionnels de santé ont mené une
campagne de vaccination contre la grippe
de façon remarquable c'est inutile
les français sont fatigués des effets
d'annoncés et attendent aujourd'hui des
actes gouverner un pays c'est fédérer
ses habitants pour lutter et combattre
ayez la modestie de reconnaître vos
erreurs comme l'a fait angela merkel qui
disait qu'une erreur doit être reconnu
comme et surtout elle doit être corrigé
ceci est la condition pour que de votre
parole redevienne crédible et peut-être
vous verrez que la france n'est pas
comme certains le croient
une nation de 66 millions de procureur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à l'autre collègue jacques
lui ni pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole merci merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des affaires
étrangères en tant que président du
groupe d'amitié france afghanistan il
est de mon devoir d'exprimer notre
inquiétude concernant la situation dans
ce pays
le retrait des troupes américaines prévu
au 1er mai fait craindre une nouvelle
déstabilisation de ce pays
le risque est réel de voir les talibans
revenir au pouvoir
c'est ce que nous a confié le fils du
commandant massoud reçu ce matin par le
président gérard larcher
dans le même temps monsieur le ministre
vous avez rencontré vos homologues de
l'otan pour aborder le dossier afghan
parralèlement des négociations sont en
cours entre les états unis la chine la
russie le pakistan l'inde le
gouvernement afghan et les talibans
négociations dont la france et l'europe
sont exclus pourtant nous serions bien
concerné si ce pays sombrait de nouveau
dans le chaos
lorsqu il s'exile c'est en europe que
vont la majorité des affluents en france
ils sont la première nationalité parmi
les demandeurs d'asile adultes
monsieur abdullah suivant les
orientations américaines négocient avec
les talibans pour le gouvernement afghan
il nous a confié personnellement
favorable à la participation des
européens aux négociations
monsieur le ministre la france et
l'europe peuvent-elles intégrer la table
des négociations sur le devenir de
l'afghanistan est ce la position que
vous avez défendu à bruxelles la semaine
dernière
comment la france peut-elle peser dans
cette crise
pour vous répondre la parole au
secrétaire d'état en charge des affaires
européennes monsieur bonne vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le nay vous avez tout à fait
raison la situation en afghanistan est
extrêmement préoccupante
la décision de retrait des troupes
américaines n'est pas remise en cause
mais sa date reste incertaine alors même
qu approche en effet l'échéance du 1er
mai notre priorité reste aux côtés des
américains un cessez-le-feu
l'instauration d'une paix durable est
l'engagement que vous portez aux côtés
de l'afghanistan que nous portons aussi
nous l'avons exprimée en participant à
la cérémonie
j'étais pour le ministère des affaires
étrangères samedi matin en hommage au
commandant massoud en présence de son
fils et le docteur abdullah abdullah
lors de la réunion ministérielle de
l'otan vous l'avez rappelé la semaine
dernière jean yves le drian qui
représentait notre pays a rappelé qu'à
un retrait des troupes alliées ne devait
être liée qu'au progrès de la
stabilisation de la situation politique
et sécuritaire est très étroitement
coordonnées entre alliés le milieu de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères a
également eu des échanges avec la partie
afghane pour essayer de débloquer les
négociations inter afghane qui ont très
peu progressé depuis leur lancement à
doha en septembre 2020 et à l'occasion
de ses entretiens avec son homologue
monsieur atmar avec monsieur abdullah
abdullah qui préside le haut conseil
pour la réconciliation nationale
il a rappelé le soutien de la france au
processus de paix il a insisté pour que
les discussions soient élargies
inclusive et très concrètement qu'il
était dans l'intérêt des parties afghane
des républicains afghans que l'union
européenne participe à ces discussions
compte tenu de l'importance que nous
attachons à la préservation des acquis
démocratiques et aux droits de l'homme
notre pays participe par ailleurs au
dialogue régionaux une conférence
ministérielle s'est tenue hier nous
avons tenu le même discours
la france est un pays soutient de ce
processus de dialogue régional depuis
maintenant 10 ans nous avons donc
plaider aussi à cette occasion encore
hier pour que les européens qui je le
rappelle sont les principaux donateurs
et dont la somme des acteurs sur place
fournissent la majorité des personnels
de l'otan nous devons le rappeler soit
plus associé associées aux initiatives
et aux discussions inter afghane 7
revendication que vous soulignez nous la
portons et nous continuerons à le faire
je souligne pour terminer que notre
compatriote et jean arnault a été nommé
mi mars envoyé personnel du secrétaire
général des nations unies sur
l'afghanistan
il contribuera aussi à cet effort
d'élargissement de la participation
européenne
je vous remercie monsieur le nez un
retour des talibans sans élection serait
une catastrophe pour la démocratie les
droits fondamentaux et les droits des
femmes la population risque d'être
soumise à une charia très durs comme
entre 1996 et 2001 faji à coup fut
membre de l'équipe de négociation
qualifié son pays de pire pays du monde
où notre tour une fille une déclaration
qui en dit long
la parole est à notre collègue céline
brulin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes avaient
la parole
merci monsieur le président ce soir
l'oracle parlera mais cet exercice
solitaire du pouvoir ne nous fera pas
renoncer à notre rôle de parlementaire
ni à notre volonté d'associer les
français à la gestion de la crise plutôt
que de jouer avec leurs nerfs et de les
infantiliser
pourquoi en sommes-nous là dans nos
écoles monsieur le ministre
parce que seulement trois cent vingt
mille tests ont été réalisés sur plus de
12 millions d'élèves
parce que nous manquons cruellement
d'enseignants remplaçants
c'est déjà tendu en temps normal alors
évidemment actuellement on brasse des
milliers d'enfants les répartitions dans
les autres classes au mépris de la
distanciation et des conditions
d'enseignement
nous en sommes là parce que vous avez
refusé que les personnels enseignants
les personnels des collectivités les un
message les assistants d'éducation
soient vaccinés les équipes sont
aujourd'hui épuisés les élus locaux
désemparés les familles inquiètes
quel est le scénario pour les jours à
venir
comment la continuité pédagogique sera
elle assurée lorsqu'une classe ou une
école voire davantage seront contraintes
de fermer
quid des collèges des lycées de
l'université la france va récupérer deux
millions de vaccins dans les prochains
jours ils doivent être destiné
prioritairement aux personnels éducatifs
avec un plan précis de vaccination les
tests salivaires pour les élèves comme
pour les personnels doivent simplifier
et être répétée chaque semaine au
passage abandonné la franchise médicale
d'un euro absolument déplacé dans le
contexte il faut aussi stopper les
suppressions de postes est recruté à la
rentrée 2021 aucune classe ne doit être
surchargés qu'on vous répondre la parole
est obligée de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je pense que dans tout ce qu'elle vous
avez tout ce que vous avez dit il ya
peut-être un point qui pourrait faire
consensus entre nous c'est que c'est une
chance pour la france que d'avoir eu ces
écoles ouvertes de septembre jusqu'à
aujourd'hui sur la nous singularise dans
l'ensemble du monde occidental en europe
et dans les amériques très peu de pays
ont fait cela mais ceci est un gain
considérable pour nos élèves dont il y
avait une sensibilité humaniste et il
est bien à l'esprit qu'en ce moment
l'unesco l'a dit 100 millions d'enfants
100 millions d'enfants sont en retard de
lecture à l'échelle du monde à cause des
confinement des écoles c'est cela la
réalité est bien il n'ya pas les
français dans ces 100 millions d'enfants
je suis malheureux pour ces enfants là
je suis heureux pour les enfants
français à qui on a fait échapper à cela
alors oui bien sûr il ya des
inconvénients de la vie quotidienne ou
ne trouverez aucun pays où il n'ya pas
d'inconvénient de la vie quotidienne
mais je vois justement des acteurs de
l'éducation nationale totalement
mobilisés parce qu'ils saisissent bien
le sens de ce que nous faisons les tests
salivaires 300000 on peut demander plus
néanmoins c'est ce que c'est laid mais
c'est le plus grand nombre de tests
salivaires hebdomadaire en europe
nous avons un taux d'acceptation de
c'était ce qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
n'est pas tel n'est pas aussi bon que ce
qu'on voudrait s'il est de 70% au moment
où je vous parle je pourrais prendre
chacun des exemples de la politique
menée pour vous dire que nous faisons le
maximum ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est que nous continuons dans cette
voie
quelles que soient les éléments de la
déclaration du président de la
république ce soir nous savons tous que
le principes qui l'animent
c'est la priorité à l'enfance et à la
jeunesse et cette priorité elle doit
être française
européenne elle doit être mondiale parce
que les enfants les jeunes peuvent en
effet être les premières victimes de
cette crise alors sur ce sujet-là de
grâce ayons l'esprit de consensus ayant
l'esprit d'unité nationale parce que ce
que nous décidons c'est dans l'intérêt
des enfants et nous le décidons sur
chacun des sujets que vous avez vu
certainement avec des imperfections si
vous voulez que je reconnaisse je le
ferai bien volontiers mais en tout cas
avec cette idée partagée avec le premier
ministre que bien entendu
l'école est la première des priorités
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre j'ai cru un instant
un instant ce midi que le gouvernement
allait reconnaître ses erreurs il n'en
est rien j'en suis vraiment navré si
vous voulez l'unité nationale accédé aux
demandes des enseignants et des
personnels éducatifs d'être vacciné si
vous voulez l'unité nationale cesser de
fermer des classes à la rentrée
tout le monde ici tout le monde dans le
pays vous le demande quand allez vous
enfin l'entendre ici la parole et vatan
notre collègue richard yung pour le
groupe du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole merci merci monsieur le
président ma question est relative au
plan de relance européen
quand il a été adopté en août ou en
septembre de l'année dernière de 2020
nous avons été très nombreux à nous
réjouir parce que c'était une action
forte par rapport à la crise du coc vide
et c'était en même temps un acte de
solidarité entre les pays européens
c'était la première fois que ça arrive
et je rappelle que c'est un plan de 750
milliards
et puis malheureusement le calendrier a
un peu dérapé par la suite pas de notre
faute pas de la faute de la france mais
il a fallu discuter avec les pays
un peu du nord un peu radin qui voulait
pas participer
il a fallu discuter avec la pologne avec
la hongrie qui voulait pas de
conditionnalité entre leur mauvaise
politique de droits de l'homme et et le
plan etc
à la fin de l'année finalement on y
arrivait il avait été adoptée par le
parlement européen par le conseil
européen
évidemment par la commission et nous
entrons dans la phase des ratifications
nationales et malheureusement patatras
il ya une semaine la cour
constitutionnelle de karlsruhe en
allemagne décide prend un arrêt
considérant que ce plan est contraire à
la loi fondamentale allemands en ce
qu'il crée une dette commune que les
allemands évidemment ne veulent pas
soutenir les pays du nord ne veulent pas
payer pour les pays qui chante le soir
dans le sud
voilà alors mais mac mais question
monsieur le ministre les suivantes
qu'est ce que la france qui n'est pas
directement responsable mepha qui voit
les choses qu est ce qu est ce que la
france peut faire quelque chose pour
accélérer le calendrier parce que sinon
nous allons arriver à un plan de relance
au moment où il y aura je l'espère la
fin de la pandémie
deuxième question nous nous qui sommes
favorables à l'amitié avec l'allemagne
qui sommes des fils aux germains nous
voyons que les relations avec
l'allemagne où plus rien plus difficile
pouvez-vous
nous dire ce que vous en pensez et enfin
ce qu'il faut pas augmenter ce plat
qu'en conclure d'éplucher goût là je dis
jeudi une seule phrase est ce que ne
faut pas augmenter ce plan de 750
milliards comme les américains l'ont
fait rappel chacun à tenir plus tôt son
temps
la parole est aux secrétaires d'état
recherche des affaires européennes
monsieur ghosn vous avez la parole
chez le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
richard yung merci pour cette question
sur un sujet sur un sujet extrêmement
important vous avez rappelé d'ailleurs
la célérité avec laquelle la france
après les différentes péripéties que
nous avons connues collectivement pour
faire avancer ce plan de relance a
permis le vote par les deux assemblées
début février deux des ressources qui
permettent de financer ce plan de
relance et notamment la dette commune
qui a été l'originalité de ce plan et
donc nous continuons ce processus de
ratification nationale qui est une
exigence démocratique légitime
je rappelle que d'habitude ce processus
prend plus de deux ans et que c'est non
seulement de plans de relance et 750
milliards d'euros qui se trouve ainsi
autorisé à la ratification mais aussi
l'ensemble du budget européen sur les
sept prochaines années ce qui représente
un total de plus de 1800 milliards
d'euros donc le débat démocratique me
semblait nécessaire sur de telles sommes
j'espère que ce processus pourrait être
achevée dans les 27 états membres d'ici
le mois de mai 16
si je compte l'allemagne avec la
suspension vous avez évoquées ont fait
ont achevé leur procédure parlementaire
c'est un record je le signale et nous
avons effectivement ça fait partie des
procédures qui peuvent s'appliquer en
allemagne ce recours devant le la cour
constitutionnelle de karlsruhe
je n'ai pas d'éléments parce que la
course est serrée de manière
indépendante à la fois sur le fond et
sur le délai néanmoins les signaux que
nous donnent les autorités allemandes
les experts juridiques de ces matières
sensibles font que nous sommes
optimistes sur une décision rapide et
positive qui nous permettra d'avancer et
de tenir l'objectif que nous fixions
c'est à dire d'avoir des décaissements
des préfinancements européen d
l'été prochain j'apporte une précision
très importante
cela ne ralentit en rien le plan de
relance français les 100 milliards
d'euros est d'ores et déjà il y a un
impact européen si je peux le dire ainsi
dans ce plan de relance français puisque
nous l'avons construit bruno le maire et
olivier dussopt d'un particulier pour
qu'ils fassent 100 milliards d'euros en
misant sur les financements qu'ils
dépasseront 40 milliards d'euros
devenant de l'union européenne si nous
n'avions pas cette garantie et cette
perspective nous n'aurions pas pu faire
un plan de relance aussi ambitieux et ce
plan de relance a commencé vous le savez
à présent plus puisque 26 milliards
d'euros sont engagés nous continuerons
cette discussion
quitte à augmenter cette réponse à
l'avenir mais faisons le d'abord
fonctionner merci beaucoup merci ta
parole est un autre collègue françois
bonhomme pour le groupe est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président il y à peu
l'unef a confirmé très tranquillement
qu'elle organisait bien des réunions
réservées aux personnes de couleur et
lorsque des voix se sont élevées pour
dénoncer ces réunions selon la couleur
de peau l'unef a persisté à signer non
seulement l'unef s'obstine mais des
responsables publics n'hésitent pas à
justifier une pratique dont on imagine
le tollé qu'elle aurait à juste titre
suscite et si une association un
syndicat en france avait organisé à
linverse des groupes de paroles laservue
au blanc bien sûr les membres du
gouvernement se sont exprimés sur cette
dérive
j'ai entendu monsieur blanc caire j'ai
entendu madame chapa quittait de son
couple et la condamnation à chaque fois
s'est voulu ferme dans les propos en
tout cas le gouvernement ne laissera pas
faire tout cela est inacceptable at on
répété répété à l'envi et pourtant ils
m'appellent n'a pas été question ni
d'engager la mode procédure de poursuite
contre une telle pratique qui à
l'évidence relève de la loi pénale ni de
suspendre de conditionner la subvention
que verse l'état
ce syndicat et nous venons d'apprendre
dernièrement que le président la
république sur rapport du premier
ministre vient de nommer un représentant
de l'unef comme membre du conseil
économique et social
tenez vous bien au nom de la cohésion
sociale
comment pouvez vous afficher une
position madame la ministre de fermeté
impeccable au demeurant en façade et en
même temps refuser toute action contre 1
syndicats qui portent atteinte de
manière si claire et si délibéré aux
valeurs de notre république on vous
répondre la parole et ministre délégué
auprès du communiste en charge des
relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne s'est d'ailleurs
s'y colle à la présidence j'ai des idées
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs vous monsieur le sénateur
bonhomme vous interroger le gouvernement
sur la nomination d'un représentant de
l'unef au sein du conseil économique et
social et environnemental plus que cette
nomination ce que vous remettez en cause
au fond c'est la réalité la
reconnaissance de la représentativité de
l'unef
le gouvernement vous l'avez d'ailleurs
fort justement rappelé a eu
l'opportunité de s'exprimer par la voix
de nombre de ses représentants pour
condamner sans la moindre obscurité si
je peux dire les sons à moindre
ambiguïté l'organisation et les
propositions de l'unef
notre opposition comme notre fermeté
sont restés constants depuis lors mais
monsieur le sénateur on peut comme je le
fais comme nous le faisons condamner ces
pratiques tout en reconnaissant la place
d'organisations élu par les étudiants et
leur présence au sein d'institutions
expressément prévues par les textes
qu'est-ce qu'il organisations
représentatives étudiantes c'est une
organisation qui a au moins et c'est la
loi un représentant dans les conseils
nationaux à l'issue des élections
étudiantes
c'est le cas de l'unef qui est la 2e
organisations représentatives étudiantes
après la fage selon les résultats des
dernières élections la présence de
l'unef au sein du cce
c'est la démocratie monsieur le sénateur
la présence au sein du ce2 découle de la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2018 qui
prévoit que les organisations jeunes
étudiants sont représentés au conseil la
réforme du 15 janvier à quoi maintenu
cette présence elles le sont pas ce
qu'elles ont obtenus aux élections les
résultats qui leur permet d'y être le
sérieux la chambre de la société civile
organisée de la participation citoyenne
la société civile organisée présente au
cee et nécessaires à la vitalité de
notre démocratie
cette nouvelle répartition des sièges
des sièges fait suite au rapport
combrexelle remis le 5 mars au premier
ministre par un comité indépendant
j'attire votre attention monsieur le
sénateur comité
vu par la loi est composé de trois sénat
entre autres de trois sénateurs et de
trois députés le gouvernement s'est
strictement conformée aux préconisations
du rapport contre excellent et vous me
permettrez donc en conclusion de
simplement à cette occasion salué les
membres sortants du cee qui ont fait un
travail remarquable qui n'est à toutes
et à tous pour tutti merci monsieur
bonhomme
monsieur le ministre est ce que vous
mesurez ce que disent vos fiches
je me pose la question vous me parlez de
représentativité s'agit pas de
représentativité
il s'agit d'un syndicat qui a tenu les
propos qui justifie des réunions sur la
couleur de peau
est-ce que vous rendez compte de vos
propos ça tombe sous le coup de la loi
pénale
vous continuez vous persistez à ne pas
vouloir enclencher l'action publique
c'est votre droit mais ne me répondez
pas à côté on le somme vous ne faites un
prêchi prêcha habituels sur les valeurs
de ré pluie ça n'a aucun sens alors que
c'est à l'état d'intervenir et de
manière forte et vous ne le faites pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est maintenant
à notre collègue jean bernard jacques
bernard magner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous venez récemment
d'affirmer que 94 % des enseignants
absents été remplacé mais la réalité est
tout autre et il semble bien que le
chiffre que vous citez ne prennent pas
en compte toutes les absences liées à la
copie d isolement malheureusement tous
les jours en effet dans bien des
établissements du primaire comme du
secondaire des enseignants absents ne
sont pas remplacés ce site désormais sur
de longues périodes
face à cela les professeurs des écoles
organisent au mieux le service
surchargeant parfois à les classes pour
accueillir des élèves des maîtres
absents et provoquant ainsi un brassage
favorable à la propagation du virus
nous pouvons comprendre que la pandémie
actuelle complique les conditions de
recrutement d'enseignants
supplémentaires pour faire face à la
situation
cette situation de plus en plus
préoccupante d'ailleurs mais monsieur le
ministre le manque chronique
d'enseignants remplaçants étaient déjà
connues et ne pouvait qu'être aggravée
par la crise sanitaire
nous l'avions dit lors du vote du budget
2021 il fallait créer plus de postes
pour assurer le remplacement des
enseignants dont on pouvait aisément
prévoir qui serait malheureusement
frappé et aussi par la contamination
puisqu'elle a doté du gouvernement c'est
de maintenir les écoles ouvertes coûte
que coûte
alors pourquoi ne pas avoir anticipé les
moyens nécessaires lors de la
préparation de la rentrée 2020
d'ailleurs nous vous demandons de
publier des vrais chiffres du taux de
remplacement dans chaque académie cas il
semble bien qu'une certaine opacité
règne dans ce domaine aujourd'hui la
situation est difficile pour les
enseignants
elle se complique considérablement pour
les enfants qui ont déjà du fait du
confinement perdu de nombreuses heures
de cours et qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à être en situation de
décrochage des décrochages scolaires
monsieur le ministre quelles mesures
allez vous prendre au palier dès à
présent les absences des enseignants non
remplacés
comment envisagez vous la période qui
nous sépare de la fin de l'année
scolaire et enfin comment préparez vous
la rentrée 2021 dans ce contexte
jeunesse
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean-michel au caire merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur manier la
question du remplacement est une
question structurelle et une question
conjoncturelle la question structurelle
et de toute façon qu'on doit améliorer
ce sujet en france même indépendamment
de la crise sanitaire
je le dis que depuis que je suis en
fonction nous l'avons un peu améliorée
par la création de postes dans le
premier degré en particulier le budget
que vous allez voter sondés sont des
budgets d'augmentation des postes au
premier deux dans le premier degré dont
l'augmentation des moyens de
remplacement et c'est ce qui nous permet
d'avoir un taux de remplacement qui
souvent selon les académies se situe
autour de 95 97 % mais c'est toujours
extrêmement désagréable pour ceux qui
sont concernés y compris les parents
d'élèves
lorsque deux trois ou quatre pour cent
quand on est dans les deux ou trois ou
quatre pour cent la crise sanitaire nous
fait descendre en dessous de ceux là on
reste au dessus de 90 %
je n'ai aucun problème pour être
transparents là dessus chacun peut
comprendre qu'une crise de cette nature
alors qu'elle nous permet de garder
l'essentiel des classes ouvertes
c'est au tour de 0 2% le nombre de
classes fermées comporte un certain
nombre d'inconvénients donc des tensions
sur le sujet du remplacement qui n'est
pas je le rappelle que une question
postes dans le second degré parfois nous
avons les postes mais nous n'avons pas
les personnes par exemple quand s'est
éloigné c'est des sujets techniques
complexes comme chacun le sait mais qui
suppose des améliorations alors pour
vous répondre rapidement je dirais deux
choses la première est structurel par
delà la crise c'est que nous sommes
faisons grenelle de l'éducation
actuellement que parmi les sujets il ya
le remplacement et par notre
organisation et nos moyens nous
améliorons cela à la rentrée prochaine
et puis les sur la dimension
conjoncturelle c'est à dire ce qui se
passe nous avons contrairement à ce que
vous avez dit améliorer les moyens en la
matière aussi bien la rentrée de
septembre par les créations de postes et
au mois de novembre
en décidant plus de 1000 support
supplémentaire pour le remplacement est
là avec l'autorisation du premier
ministre j'ai annoncé la semaine
dernière qui donnerait les moyens de
remplacement supplémentaires académie
par académie pour pourvoir les postes
donc oui il
évidemment une tension sur le
remplacement je le reconnais mais oui
nous sommes évidemment en situation de
travailler pour répondre à ce problème
parce que en effet il doit y avoir
toujours chaque fois qu'on le peut un
professeur devant chaque élève
chacun comprendra les circonstances
exceptionnelles que nous traversons que
bien sûr il peut y avoir des problèmes
mais que nous sommes organisés je veux
rendre hommage
l'ensemble des personnels de l'éducation
nationale qui nous permettent de tenir
dans ces circonstances si difficiles
là où d'autres n'ont pas tenu merci
merci
la parole est à d'autres collègues
antoine lefèvre pour le gros père est
plus qu un merci monsieur le président
ma question à laquelle j'associe mes
collègues jacky d'euromédis et catherine
procas ya s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie et porte sur les menaces de
fermetures de comptes bancaires de nos
compatriotes dix américains accidentelle
ceux-ci environ 40000 en france 300
milles en europe seulement né sur le sol
américain sont néanmoins du fait du
traité fact a conclu en 2013 assujettis
à des obligations fiscales américaines
du seul fait du droit du sol les banques
françaises sont tenus de transmettre un
numéro fiscal pour leurs clients
considérés comme américain sous peine de
lourdes sanctions financières mais elle
avait obtenu un délai or en ce début
d'année 2021 la banque bnp paribas qui
s'est vu infliger une amende de plus de
9 milliards de dollars en 2014 menace de
façon plutôt énergique de clôturer ses
comptes unilatéralement et sous 2 mois y
compris quand il ya un prêt immobilier
en cours au prétexte que ses
souscripteurs ne peuvent produire ce
fameux numéro en 2018 dans cette
assemblée à l'initiative de jacky
d'euromédis nous avons voté à
l'unanimité une résolution invitant le
gouvernement à la mise en oeuvre d'une
action diplomatique temps d'en obtenir
un traitement dérogatoire pour les
américains accidentelle leur permettant
soit de renoncer à la citoyenneté
américaine pour une procédure simple et
gratuite soit d'être exonéré
l'obligation fiscale américaine
or l'ensemble des services de
l'ambassade étant fermées depuis mars
2020 en raison du contexte sanitaire
il est donc pas possible pour nos
concitoyens et aux etats-unis avant 1986
et qui n'ont pas ce numéro
d'identification ni de récupérer ce
fameux numéro 10 de renoncer à la
nationalité américaine
les banques ne peuvent donc méconnaître
cette difficulté insurmontable
les pays bas ont d'ailleurs abordé le
sujet lors de la réunion des ministres
européens des finances le 16 février et
leur ministre s'est engagé devant les
parlementaires
une négociation bilatérale avec son
homologue américain monsieur le ministre
cette situation et les menaces dont sont
victimes nos compatriotes nécessite une
action volontaire vers la nouvelle
administration maiden que nous savons
attaché au partenariat transatlantique
pouvez vous nous faire le point sur
l'avancement de ce dossier et faire en
sorte que le harcèlement de certaines
banques cessent pour vous répondre la
parole de tout ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics
vous avez la parole est retirée mais
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
si la terre monsieur le sénateur
lefebvre vous l'avez dit dépuis 2013 les
gouvernements successifs sont mobilisés
avec d'autres gouvernements européens
faire en sorte que ce que nous appelons
les américains accidentelle puisse
renoncer plus facilement à la
nationalité américaine quand ils le
souhaitent et d'ailleurs un guichet
spécial a été mis en place par
l'ambassade et le consulat avant la
période de coville qui leur permet une
procédure simplifiée qui leur permet de
le faire sans obtention du numéro
d'identification fiscale que vous avez
rappelé mais il faut souligner que cette
procédure est assujettie à une taxe
américaine de 2350 dollar
il y à une sortante de difficultés qui
ont pu être rencontré et vous avez
pointé les cinq études que certains
américains accidentelle pour reprendre
ce terme peuvent entretenir du fait du
positionnement des établissements
bancaires devraient apporter de réponses
à vos interrogations de nature à les
rassurer
d'abord pour dire que dernièrement nous
avons obtenu de la part de lire est ce
qui est le service fiscal américain la
possibilité d'utiliser des codes par les
établissements financiers pour les
résidents fiscaux américains qui ne
bénéficient pas du numéro
d'identification fiscale numéro dont
vous avez rappelé la difficulté est
parfois la possibilité qu'ils avaient à
le retrouver ou à le trouver
ces codes pourront être utilisés dès la
campagne de collecte 2021 et permettront
de mieux cerner les difficultés liées à
la note la non obtention des numéros
d'identification fiscale nord-américain
et de faciliter la résolution
je veux aussi vous indiquer que rien ne
justifie une fermeture de compte sur le
seul fondement qu'un client est
américain que ce soit un américain
accidentel ou pas ou sur le fait qu'il
est dans l'impossibilité de fournir un
numéro d'identification fiscale qui
puisait numéro d'identification fiscale
à l'étranger selon la doctrine de
l'administration fiscale française
qui a été expressément rappelé la
fédération bancaire récemment la
procédure couvre les banques en cas
d'absence de numéro d'identification
fiscale qui plaisait nord américain et
celle ci les banques ne relève que la
loi française pour la collecte et la
transmission d'informations à la djs un
sujet sur lequel nous portons la plus
grande attention vous avez souligné
et si tu es un établissement bancaire
dont nous allons nous rapprocher pour
faire en sorte que ces américains dit
accidentelle n'est pas souffrir de la
situation administrative dans laquelle
ils sont merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue olivier cigolotti pour le
groupe de l'union centriste de
l'appareil merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
également à monsieur le ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre alors que les
maires préparent leur budget primitif
2021 ces derniers sont inquiets et en
colère
en effet les maires et présidents de pci
sont en première ligne pour lutter
contre la pandémie et ses conséquences
dès le début du premier confinement les
acteurs locaux ont multiplié les
initiatives et mobilisé de nombreuses
ressources proposées pour protéger leurs
concitoyens maintenir les services
publics et soutenir les tissus
économiques associatifs
cette crise produit actuellement un choc
violent sur les finances des
collectivités locales ces répercussions
d'antan seront irréversibles dans ce
contexte l'automatisation du ctv est
entrée en vigueur le 1er janvier 2021
cette réforme s'applique aux dépenses
effectuées dès ce début d'année
ainsi pour l'ensemble des bénéficiaires
du rsa tva les dépenses 2021 et au delà
seront donc traitées dans le cadre de
nouvelles modalités de gestion du fait
de cette réforme
des ajustements ont été opérés à compter
de cette année les dépenses inscrites
sur les comptes de 111 et 212 terrain et
aménagement terrain ainsi que les
travaux d'investissements réalisés en
régie ne bénéficieront plus de la
compensation à la grande surprise des
élus et de leurs associations
l'élaboration la modification et la
révision des documents d'urbanisme ne
seront plus non plus éligible ces
dépenses conséquentes sont souvent
amorti sur une durée de 10 ans et pèse
de façon importante sur le budget des
collectivités
l'incidence de ces pertes d'éligibilité
de fctva sera extrêmement dommageable
le bloc communal temps sur les documents
d'urbanisme indispensable au
développement des territoires que pour
des aménagements terrain et notamment
des terrains dédiés au sport
monsieur le ministre à la date du 15
avril les éléments nécessaires à la
préparation budgétaire auront ils été
transmis aux collectivités
cette date demeurera-t-elle inchangé et
surtout quelle mesure entendez vous
prendre pour établir l'éligibilité où
elle s'est élevée à des documents
d'urbanisme et des aménagements terrain
je vous remercie
la parole les communistes de léguer
olivier dussopt up
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur cigolotti l'automatisation du
fctva est une bonne réforme
une bonne réforme parce qu'elle va
permettre de passer d'un régime
déclaratif un régime automatique et nous
savons que lorsque cette réforme se
rentrait totalement en vigueur le gain
pour les collectivités à périmètre
constant est estimé à 235 millions
d'euros cette année intègrent le régime
automatique de décoration du fctva les
seules collectivités qui bénéficient du
remboursement du fctva en année n
c'est à dire une minorité de
collectivités l'année prochaine ce sera
les collectivités en puissance puis en
plus de tous les maires savent à quel
rythme le fctva et perçu cette
automatisation qui va aussi permettre de
générer des économies de fonctionnement
s'est traduite mais pas seulement
l'automatisation par des entrées les
sorties du périmètre d'éligibilité les
travaux d'entretien de voirie par
exemple avait été intégré il ya quelques
années les travaux de réseaux on est
intégrés récemment il est vrai que les
terrains à bâtir et les documents
d'urbanisme ont été retirés de
l'éligibilité vous l'avez souligné
je tiens à souligner que nous devons
travailler avec jacqueline gourault
c'est la question des terrains à bâtir
sur la question des documents
d'urbanisme
je partage - le ton père un peu révolté
de votre question dans la mesure où ces
dépenses de documents d'urbanisme
représente 0,3 pour cent du total du
fctva
vous conviendrez avec moi que ce n'est
pas la majeure partie de cette
allocation de 6 milliards d'euros
nous aurons l'occasion dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois de travailler sur ces questions là
et de rendre l'automatisation tout à
fait perfectible c'était d'ailleurs
l'objectif que nous avions avec cette
entrée en vigueur progressive sur trois
ans du fctva
je saisis l'occasion de votre question
pour souligner que pour ce qui concerne
les collecter
thé local les chiffres ont été rendus
définitif et public par l'insee
l'évolution des recettes des
collectivités locales a été marquée en
2020 comme l'ensemble des recettes
publiques par une légère diminution d'à
peu près 2% que les dépenses des
collectivités de manière très générale
de manière macroéconomiques n'ont
augmenté que de 0 2% mais avec des
différences entre les strates et
l'excédent réalisé en 2019 fait que ce
légère effet ciseau se traduit pour 2020
par un compte des collectivités locales
qui est à l'équilibré avec un solde à l'
équilibre ce qui est plutôt rations et
le maintien d'une capacité d'epargne
égale à celle de 2018 là aussi c'est un
recul mais qui permet de rester sur des
bases intéressantes pour justifier les
capacités d'investissement des
collectivités
merci la parole qu'à notre collègue
guillaume chevrollier pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur le ministre il ya
quelques jours j'ai rencontré des jeunes
de terminale au lycée lavoisier de la
ville de mayenne ils m'ont fait part de
leur grande inquiétude
à trois mois du baccalauréat sur
l'épreuve du grand oral c'était preuve
finale inédite et la grande nouveauté du
bac
elle est déterminante elle un
coefficient important les lycéens y
travaillent sont studieux il a envie de
donner le meilleur d'eux mêmes mais
comment se préparait à une épreuve
lorsqu'on n'en connais pas les modalités
cette inquiétude est partagée par tous
les professeurs formés tardivement sont
écartelés entre la nécessité de terminer
le programme ou préparer les élèves à
l'oral les lycéens se demande si
l'épreuve sera bien maintenu ou annulé
comme l'oral de français l'année
dernière
il ya aussi les questions très basique
portant sur l'organisation de l'épreuve
auquel personne est en capacité de
répondre
de plus la situation sanitaire impose à
certains lycées de fonctionner de
manière hybride en présentiel en
distance yale les élèves n'auront donc
pas les mêmes conditions de préparation
à cet examen
pourtant nationale ce rite de passage
fort dans la vie d'un jeune adulte à
cette inégalité s'ajoutent celles
dénoncées par les bacheliers des
établissements privés
contrat les candidats libres et ceux
inscrits en cours à distance et même le
cned réglementée ils seront les seuls à
ne pas bénéficier du contrôle continu
comme leurs camarades du public et du
privé sous contrat avec l'état
ces différences de traitement entre les
élèves constitue une rupture d'égalité
devant l'examen monsieur le ministre les
jeunes les parents les professeurs les
élus locaux m'interpelle sur l'urgence
de soutenir la jeunesse
quel est votre message pour les rassurer
et ils sont dans l'attenté
d'informations très claires et concrètes
sur les modalités du grand oral pouvez
vous nous les précisé monsieur mais les
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports va vous répondre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je vous remercie pour votre
question qui est l'occasion
vous l'avez un peu fait d'ailleurs de
souligner l'importance de cette
innovation dans la réforme du
baccalauréat
je rappelle que cette innovation qui a
une des plus importantes à l'intérieur
de cette réforme est faite pour envoyer
un message à l'ensemble du système
éducatif depuis l'école maternelle
jusqu'à la terminale et c'est
l'importance de l'oral l'importance de
la capacité à s'exprimer l'importance de
ce extraverti re l'importance d'écouter
l'importance d'argumenter nous savons
que ce ne sont pas forcément des points
forts de notre système
c'est très complémentaire de la
compétence est écrite et nous voulons la
développé par toute une série
d'initiatives dans le détail desquels je
ne peux pas rentrer mais par exemple la
pratique théâtrale le chant etc
c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'école de la
confiance c'est aussi pour cela donner
confiance en soi aux élèves et leur
permettre de s'exprimer mais entendu la
situation actuelle remet en cause à
chaque fois tous les éléments de notre
système et nous oblige à des adaptations
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs nous avons
procédé déjà des adaptations à ce stade
je considère que cette épreuve peut
avoir lieu comme d'ailleurs sommes
capables de le faire dès lors que les
conditions au mois de juin évidemment le
permettront cette épreuve aura un grand
intérêt bien entendu nous l'organiserons
avec bienveillance ces faits pour que
les élèves réussissent mais c'est un
très bon signal que de leur dire qu'il
est important de s'entraîner ce qui
n'est pas exact dans votre question
c'est de dire que nous n'avons pas donné
les ressources chacun peut le vérifier
immédiatement sur le site
education.gouv.fr aussi sur notre site
eduscol avec à la fois l'explication du
grand oral contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit c'est très clair vous êtes en
trois parties qui sont explicités
deuxièmement des ressources pour
s'entraîner alors bien entendu comme
c'est une première il peut y avoir des
éléments nouveaux qui pose des questions
c'est bien normal
eh bien les professeurs évidemment
peuvent encore poser toutes les
questions les corps d'inspection sur là
pour les aider
ce que nous faisons sur ce sujet depuis
des mois maintenant c'est de la
formation continue pour les professeurs
et encore une fois je le répète tout
ceci est fait pour faire réussir les
élèves puisque la philosophie de la
réforme du baccalauréat c'est de dire
que en préparant le baccalauréat
on prépare ce qui va faire réussir après
le baccalauréat est donc ce que nous
voulons pour les élèves c'est pas les
brimer au travers d'une épreuve qui
serait pénible c'est au contraire leur
permettent de s'entraîner pour quelque
chose qui va leur être utile par la
suite et notamment leur réussite dans
l'enseignement supérieur
je vous remercie quelques secondes pour
monsieur chevrollier oui merci raymond
résidents monsieur me soit ma question
du terrain les modalités ne semble pas
connus par les acteurs de terrain par
les lycéens qui sont inquiets et de
mémoire de professeurs qui ont connu des
réformes sous la droite et soûlé gauche
jamais ils ont été dans une
impréparation les choses étaient connus
dès la rentrée scolaire là c'est pas le
cas avec votre gouvernement et je le
regrette
merci la parole est à notre collègue
michel meunier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et république à vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'enfance
et des familles depuis l'annnonce du
programme d'accompagnement des 1000
premiers jours de l'enfant
nous ne pouvons reprocher
au ministre adrien attaqué de manquer
d'ambition en matière de petite enfance
et de soutien à la parentalité
pour autant cet intérêt masquent mal les
difficultés éprouvées sur le terrain
difficulté par les familles à la
recherche de solutions d'accueil de
leurs jeunes enfants et difficulté par
les professionnels mobilisés pour leurs
conditions de travail que ce soit à
domicile dans les maisons d'assistantes
maternelles ou dans les crèches
hier mes chers collègues le secteur de
la petite enfance étaient en grève pour
dénoncer la réforme qui est règlement
des règlementera les conditions
d'accueil des jeunes enfants réforme par
ordonnance et par décret baisse de
l'encadrement permission d'accueil en
surnombre diminution des superficies
diminution de la qualité éducative
en clair moins de personnel qualifié et
des budgets de formation insuffisant
le haut conseil de la famille de l'âge
de l'enfant cde l'âge a donné un avis
plus que réservé sur ses perspectives
le rapport d'experts autour de boris
cyrulnik préconise un accueil réalisés
par des professionnels qualifiés pour
garantir le développement et
l'épanouissement du jeune enfant vos
projets s'en éloigne alors monsieur le
ministre ma question est la suivante
visez-vous seulement à renforcer les
équilibres financiers les entreprises de
crèches privées au détriment de la
qualité de l'accueil de la petite
enfance pour vous répondre la parole et
aux milices de lyon charte de
l'autonomie
vous avez la parole madame le président
madame la sénatrice michel meunier je
vous prie de bien vouloir excuser mon
collègue adrien tac et secrétaires
d'état chargés de l'enfance et des
familles retenues mais évidemment
pleinement mobilisés sur les questions
relatives à la petite enfance que vous
évoquez il a d'ailleurs tenu à rendre un
vibrant hommage pour l'engagement des
professionnels et la mobilisation qu'ils
ont pu pendant leur activité face à la
crise sanitaire pour toujours mieux
accompagner les plus petits dans un
récent courrier
j'ai aussi l'occasion à ce niveau au nom
du gouvernement de réaffirmer la place
de ces professionnels dans la politique
de lutte
contre les inégalités de destin et de
défense de l'égalité des chances dès le
plus jeune âge
pour cela la ned 2021 est une année
décisive vous l'avez rappelé elle verra
l'aboutissement de la réforme des règles
applicables aux modes d'accueil du jeune
enfant
après plus de deux ans de concertation
et de travail
ces nouvelles règles doivent permettre
aux professionnels de se consacrer à
leur coeur de métier par la
simplification et la lisibilité
notamment
elle se place dans un cap clair celui de
la qualité de l'accueil tels que définis
par la charte nationale consacraient
certains considèrent qu'on ne va pas
assez vite ou qu'on ne va pas assez loin
mais je sais qu adrien taquet a souhaité
promouvoir une solution d'équilibré pour
ne pas rester dans un statu quo par
ailleurs pour préserver l'emploi
face à la crise la branche famille
mobilise 200 millions d'euros pour
assurer un plan de relance avec un
soutien à l'investissement notamment
puissant l'aurait ossements des aides au
fonctionnement dans les territoires
prioritaires
une expérimentation inédite d'un
accompagnement au montage de projets
vous le voyez le gouvernement poursuit
donc son action dans le bon sens
notamment en direction des
professionnels de la petite enfance
merci voilà meunier si madame la
ministre
j'entends vos propos et l'image que vous
dépeignez est une image idéale mais à
l'image de ce qui se passe dans les
ehpad secteur que vous connaissez bien
nous craignons que la petite enfance
devienne un secteur parent pauvre de
l'accompagnement social
merci lui donner la parole à notre
collègue jean bacci pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
ouais ça monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
on le voit dans la banlieue de
strasbourg poursuivre un homme en quad
dans le jardin d'un particulier dans la
drôme s'attaque en étudiant un chien
domestique aux abords de nos villages
alpins à part dans la manche il a été
repéré partout en france le loup devient
un véritable fléau dans nos campagnes
étendant son territoire à la recherche
de nourriture
l'homme ne lui fait plus peur dans le
var à la verdière ce sont 300 bêtes de
troupeaux du troupeau de l'éleveur
locales qui ont été tuées en 2000 avec
le loup est même entré dans la bergerie
dans le var toujours en 2020 et 63 168
attaque 1156 victimes 13 m identifier et
ces chiffres croise chaque année outre
le coût de financiers il ya une profonde
lassitude chez les éleveurs de plus en
plus si j'ai très peu de fautes de se
sentir soutenu par les pouvoirs publics
la question du loup c'est également
celle de la sécurité alimentaire car le
pastoralisme disparaît de nos
territoires
alors que nous prenons le refus des
élevages intensifs outre la fermeture
des milieux et l'atteinte à la
biodiversité c'est tout simplement
l'approvisionnement en circuit court qui
en pâtit et cela au profit des
importations de nouvelle zélande et du
royaume uni
est ce l agriculture que vous voulez
monsieur le ministre mais le plan loup
c'est aussi 30 millions d'euros cette
année en augmentation régulière soit
soixante mille euros par m qu'on estime
à 580 bien que ce soit politiquement
incorrect je vous interroge qu'apporte
le loup à la biodiversité
puisqu'il n'a plus de prédateurs en
mille hommes les brigades de loups et
les louvetiers nabaat que très peu faute
de moyens et d'autorisation il faut
aujourd'hui non seulement organiser un
vrai des comptes de ce prédateur mais
aussi ajuster les autorisations
préfectorales 2-2 prélèvements et
faciliter les tirs de défense pour les
éleveurs monsieur le ministre les
éleveurs dans nos communes pastorale de
sont excédés montrez leur que vous les
entendez avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean
bacci nous avons sur ce sujet de
préoccupation extrêmement importantes à
concilier lune c'est bien la
préservation de la biodiversité et la
préservation de la biodiversité nous en
avons besoin du plus petit du papillon
de la bei au plus gros aux grands
prédateurs c'est toute la chaîne de la
biodiversité que nous devons préserver
et ce sont les engagements que nous
avons pris en signant la convention de
berne en 1979 pour la réintroduction
maîtrisée du loup et l'autre vous l'avez
dit c'est la protection de nos éleveurs
le soutien l'agropastoralisme l'année
cet élevage à soutenir cet élevage dans
nos montagnes dans nos territoires
ruraux
est ce que fait le gouvernement avec le
plan loup depuis 2018 avec toutes les
mesures prises ces deux rendre possible
cette coexistence ça veut dire des
prélèvements vous savez que des
prélèvements ont lieu avec la brigade
loudes le fbi avec les lieutenants de
louveterie nous avons augmenté le taux
possible de prélèvement qui passe
maintenant de 17 à 19% ce qui veut dire
que nous régulons la population avec des
mesures de protection et oui nous
finançons ces mesures de protection
parce que c'est le prix à payer pour
maintenir cette biodiversité et avec
l'indemnisation des éleveurs avec des
barèmes qui se sont améliorées et pour
la première fois dans certains
départements les dégâts ont baissé en
2020 donc ça veut dire que ces mesures
de protection elles sont efficaces et
elles produisent des effets est ce que
ça peut s'améliorer encore oui et le
gouvernement est prêt à être dans cette
amélioration continue pour que les
mesures soient encore plus efficace
encore plus précise encore plus en
soutien des éleveurs est-ce qu'il faut
sacrifier totalement la biodiversité au
mépris de nos engagements internationaux
au mépris de la préservation à moyen
terme de toutes les espèces non la
coexistence est indispensable et nous
allons la rendre possible
puis quelques secondes
madame la ministre vous nous parler de
biodiversité philosophique
moi je vous parle de celle du terrain je
vous invite tous à venir voir un
troupeau attaqué par une troupe par un
groupe de loups vous verrez des dizaines
de bêtes au sol est gorgé dépecer à
moitié dévoré parfois encore vivante en
train d'agoniser
et je pense pas que la cause animale et
la biodiversité y gagne beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
collègue olivier henno maire ce groupe
union centriste avait la parole monsieur
le président madame la ministre chers
collègues hier matin on pouvait lire
dans un quotidien national que les
salariés pourraient être obligés de
payer pour se former
nous n'avons pas été surpris des
chiffres dévoilés par le conseil
d'administration de france compétences
en effet au début de l'année 2018 lors
de l'examen du sénat du projet de loi
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel
nous avions tenté d'alerter le
gouvernement sur le problème du
financement de la formation
professionnelle et sur le devenir du 1%
formation mais à l'époque votre volonté
de recentralisation l'avait emporté aux
dépens du paritarisme et des compétences
des régions
aujourd'hui les faits parlent d'eux
mêmes et les salariés comme les
partenaires sociaux sont inquiets le
manque de financement s'élèverait donc à
peu près de 5 milliards d'euros pour la
période 2020 2023 et pourrait atteindre
10 milliards avec la crise sanitaire
vous avez indiqué souhaiter ouvrir une
concertation avant l'été c'est une bonne
chose
il semble urgent de réunir l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux sur ce sujet
notre groupe par la voix de notre
président avait aussi évoqué
l'organisation d'une conférence sociale
il est vrai dans un silence
gouvernemental assourdissant madame la
ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer comment le
ornements compte traiter cet important
sujet du financement de la réforme de la
formation professionnelle je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est invendable la ministre déléguée
chargée de l'insertion madame klinkert
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur hainaut la question de l'
équilibre financier de france
compétences et bien sûr un sujet qui est
bien identifiée et suivie avec grande
attention par le gouvernement nous
avions d'ailleurs déjà présenté dans le
projet de loi finances pour 2021
un objectif d' équilibre budgétaire pour
et ce sujet d'ailleurs inscrit également
à l'agenda social depuis l'été dernier
la situation actuelle s'explique d'une
part par des facteurs conjoncturels mais
aussi plus structurelles qui sont
inhérents au dispositif
la crise sanitaire a en effet eu un
impact sur les recettes de l'opérateur
france compétences car ce sont bien les
contributions des entreprises qui
financent la formation professionnelle
et l'apprentissage
or l'activité partielle a entraîné une
baisse des ressources
par ailleurs l'augmentation du nombre
des contrats d'apprentissage a engendré
une hausse des dépenses qui sont liées à
leur prise en charge et vous le savez
nous comptabilisons 500000 contrat
d'apprentissage en 2020 grâce au
dispositif de soutien un plan une
solution plan un jeune et solution et
cela malgré malgré le contexte de la
crise c'est là un record historique
je rappelle par ailleurs qu elisabeth
bornes et le premier ministre ont
annoncé la prolongation des aides à
l'apprentissage jusqu'à la fin de cette
année
la forte mobilisation du cps est le
dernier élément à prendre en compte nos
concitoyens sont en effet en train de se
saisir de cet outil qui permet à ce jour
de financer un éventail extrêmement
large de formations et puis depuis la
rentrée
pôle emploi
les employeurs peuvent également abondé
le cph pour financer le reste à charge
des formations des salariés
le ministère du travail étudie toutes
les pistes d'un retour progressif à
l'équilibré de france compétences ces
pistes sont partagés et feront l'objet
des changes dans le respect de la
gouvernance quadripartite de l'opérateur
et dans ce cas nous restons plus à
l'écouté de toute contribution des
parlementaires
je vous remercie monsieur hainaut oui
merci madame la ministre alors par cette
question notre groupe veut marquer deux
oppositions opposition à la création
d'un ticket modérateur qui viendrait à
reviendrait à faire payer les salariés
et les jeunes pour leur formation
opposition à la baisse à la prise en
charge des contrats d'apprentissage une
grosse inquiétude par rapport au
financement et au 1% formation et puis
un attachement double attachement au
paritarisme et puis également un
attachement à l'implication des régions
dans la formation professionnelle jour
merci à mes chers collègues pour
l'organisation du débat qui va suivre la
déclaration du gouvernement demain
relatives à l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire et aux mesures nécessaires
pour y répondre nous pourrions prévoir
attendre parents la raison d'un orateur
par le groupe
je le rappelle de 14 minutes pour le
groupe l'est républicain de 12 minutes
pour le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains de dix minutes pour le
groupe de l'union centriste de dix
minutes de huit minutes pour les autres
groupes de trois minutes pour les
sénateurs mais figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
le délai limite pour les inscriptions de
parole dans le débat pour et tétouan
fixé à demain 11 heures
nous avons procédé aux consultations
mais vous imaginez dans quelles
conditions n'est pas reçu d'avis
différents de ce que nous proposons
il en est donc ainsi décidé
et mes chers collègues je vous rappelle
en remerciant le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres que
les prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement auront lieu le mercredi 7
avril prochain la séance va être
suspendue elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
la suite de l'examen du projet de loi
comportant de respect des principes de
la république la science est suspendu
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur public
sénat et notamment et bien ces
précisions en de chara larcher autour du
débat qui se tiendra demain dans
l'hémicycle du sénat à 15 heures autour
et bien d annoncer des nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires qui devraient
être annoncées ce soir par emmanuel
macron tout de suite on va rejoindre
steve jourdain dans l'hémicycle du sénat
stif pour reparler et bien des temps
forts de cette séance beaucoup de co
vide
et puis on a parlé écoles aussi dans
l'hémicycle mais disons le thème c'était
une séance extrêmement particulière une
science un peu bizarre même une séance
hors sol on a vu un hémicycle
littéralement suspendus aux annonces à
venir aux annonces des manuels macron ce
soir 20h on a senti aussi des sénateurs
très remontés travail monter la tension
le fond de ces annonces à venir que sur
la forme
au moment et bien de la question du
socialiste bernard jomier on a senti
presque une mouche voler dans
l'hémicycle écoutez bernard jomier qui
interpelle le gouvernement
le cri va s'accélérer et pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de récente
de notre pays
ce n'est pas la conséquence d'un
événement imprévu
c'est la conséquence du choix d'un homme
qui dans une volonté de concentration à
l'excès de ses prérogatives
constitutionnelles a pris cette décision
c'est le chef de l'état monsieur le
premier ministre
allez vous exprimer des regrets des
remords des excuses vis-à-vis des
français de leurs proches qui sont
victimes de cette obstination voulais
autre moment très fort de 7
séance est ce thème consacré et bien à
l'avenir de nos écoles faute il est bien
les fermer comme le préconisent certains
experts certains épidémiologistes
réponse définitif évidemment table ce
soir 20 heures en attendant jean michel
blanquer refuse tout mea culpa écouter
mais peut-être un point qui pourrait
faire consensus entre nous c'est que
c'est une chance pour la france que
d'avoir eu ces écoles ouvertes de
septembre jusqu'à aujourd'hui sur la
nous singularise dans l'ensemble du
monde occidental en europe et dans les
amériques très peu de pays ont fait cela
et ceci est un gain considérable pour
nos élèves et tous les yeux se tournent
désormais vers l'elysée l'elysée ce soir
20h dans les couloirs du sénat on évoque
une fermeture des écoles pour un moi ta
main voilà deux sources parlementaires
les écoles devraient fermer pour un mois
merci beaucoup steve tout de suite et
bien
autre actualité du sénat l'examen du
projet de loi sur le séparatisme benoît
roth bruno retailleau président du
groupe et leur tient actuellement un
printemps un point presse autour du
voile dire burqini notamment après les
mesures adoptées par la majorité
sénatoriale on va tout de suite
rejoindre la salle des conférences
voulez vous forger un texte qui ne parle
pas de séparatisme et qui ne prétend pas
lutter contre le marqueur du séparatisme
le voile le voile c'est cet étendard ce
marqueur d'une contre société qui
s'organise sur elle-même une contre
société a visé à la voix sexiste pour
dire aux femmes
quels sont les inférieure des hommes et
a visé aussi dont seulement sexiste mais
aussi séparatiste donc je me réjouis
évidemment que l'interdiction par
exemple des signes ostentatoires pour
les sorties scolaires du burkini et
aussi du voile mandé petite fille sur
lequel le gouvernement a toujours
reculer toujours toujours eh bien nous
l'avons voté
séparatisme en empêchant des mamans qui
portent un foulard d'accompagner les
enfants les toutes les femmes en france
qui porte un voile ne sont pas des
islamistes ou des terroristes et
évidemment tous les islamistes tous
imposent à leurs femmes de porter le
voile
le voile c'est l'instrument de la
soumission de la femme le voile c'est
l'étendard de 7 contre société qui veut
séparer les français les uns des autres
en fonction de leurs croyances
la république c'est la communauté des
citoyens bien sûr l'instruction en
famille c'est capital parce que le
gouvernement n'a aucune preuve ni aucune
raison et va atteindre une liberté que
aucune république
aucun gouvernement depuis 1882 avec la
loi jules ferry n'avait atteint donc
c'est facile d'être dur avec ceux qui
sont faibles avec les familles qui ont
fait le choix de l'école à la maison et
d'être plutôt mou avec les islamistes
manon veut que ce soit linverse on va
durcir le texte contre les islamistes
mais on veut préserver nos libertés
je veux pas vous dire on est au tout
début écouter on est à peine à l'article
2 c'est un texte qui en comptent bien
d'autres articles il ya d'autres enjeux
sur les listes communautariste et
d'autres encore sur aussi l'immigration
on veut durcir bien sûr comment est il
possible qu'en france une personne qui
bénéficient de l'hospitalité française
qui bénéficient du statut de réfugié qui
fait l'apologie du terrorisme
comment se fait-il que cette personne ne
soit pas expulsables est-ce que les
français peuvent comprendre cette
aberration non eh bien on va y remédier
simplement c'est simplement le bon sens
oui mais ce qui est important c'est pas
je veux dire le nom ce qui est important
c'est le contenu
voilà c'est le contenu qui nous
intéresse d'abord nous avons commencé
déjà hier soir sur la question de cet
étendard du séparatisme qui est le voile
et nous continuerons sur l'immigration
nous continuerons avec toujours plus de
fermeté parce qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
une situation qui est dramatique
le terrorisme c'est des morts mais le
terrorisme c'est aussi un djihadisme
d'atmosphère un terreau et si nous ne
luttons pas contre le terreau parce que
la république perd chaque jour chaque
mois chaque année du terrain et bien ce
terrain il faut le reconquérir
je suis retailleau ne répondait pas sur
les choses les écoles c'est une mesure
qui est nécessaire selon vous ce soir il
ya un mois qui serait fermé les écoles
jeune et j'ai déjà fait cette
proposition nous l'avions fait donc
aussi
après valérie pécresse qui avait suggéré
d'avancer les vacances scolaires ça fait
quelques semaines que fait cette
proposition c'est une proposition que
j'ai fait on verra ce soir
ce qu'en dit écoutez si c'est une mesure
que nous avons proposé d'avancer les
vacances scolaires je ne vois pas
pourquoi la soutiendrai pas mais
j'attends de savoir exactement ce qui
nous sera demandé de voter
sachant qu'une fois de plus on apprend à
la télévision les décisions et ensuite
on nous demande de les ratifier
c'est pas ça la démocratie c'est pas ça
la vie parlementaire
ça n'est pas ça c'est que jamais un
gouvernement n'a eu autant de pouvoir
la contrepartie de ce pouvoir que le
gouvernement a c'est que le parlement
soit respectée et que ça n'est pas à la
télévision qu'on apprenne les décisions
du chef de l'état tout est concentré
dans les mains d'un seul homme c'est ce
n'est pas que ça ne me satisfait pas ça
veut dire que ce n'est pas le bon ordre
de la démocratie quand nous avons
demandé sur le dd à theix sur l'état
d'urgence au gouvernement le vote du
parlement lorsqu'il s'agissait de
proroger un confinement au delà d'un
mois le gouvernement a dit non le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu que le
gouvernement le parlement puisse voter
et là on voudrait nous faire voter sur
un vote qui n'a pas de sens parce que ce
n'est pas un vote qui emporte une
conséquence c'est simplement un vote
consultatif sur des décisions qui leur
ont été déjà annoncées
donc un vote sur lequel on n'a aucun
pouvoir avait pas grand chose
voilà pour ce point presse de bruno
retailleau à la fois autour bien de ce
projet de loi examinée actuellement dans
l'hémicycle autour du séparatisme et
puis qui s'est terminée sur locaux vides
et les restrictions sanitaires qu'on
attend ce soir à 20 heures avec
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron toujours
sur le même sujet on va rejoindre
alexandre pissas requête avec un autre
président du groupe le présent du groupe
socialiste patrick kanner et on va
parler des annonces du président de la
république ce soir patrick kanner les
écoles devraient fermer avec un
allongement des vacances scolaires est
ce que ce serait la bonne décision alors
que les écoles avaient été préservés
lors du dernier confinement en tout cas
vous en savez plus loin parce que nous
en tant que parlementaire on ne sait
rien ce etc c'est quand même un jour
sans fin dans la gestion de cette
épidémie entre le gouvernement et le
parlement on est toujours mis devant le
fait accompli ce que je regrette
naturellement
en tout cas moi dès le mois de février
pendant les vacances février j'avais
proposé qu'on allonge les vacances de
février pour empêcher le virus de se
développer
ça n'avait pas été suivi à l'époque est
naturellement si cette décision était
prise on serait bien sûr d'accord pour
considérer que enfin enfin un peu de
jugement positif de la part du président
de la république dans la gestion de ces
crises donc sur la fermeture des écoles
pas en vacances vous êtes d'accord sur
un éventuel reconfirme en national et la
fin de cette stratégie territorialisées
est-ce que là aussi ce serait la bonne
solution
encore une fois là il nous manque des
informations on n'a pas les algorithmes
sur lequel se base le travail du
gouvernement
la logique aurait voulu que fin janvier
ce confinement nationale est assez lourd
soit programmé organisé pour justement
éviter que le variant angles et se
développe comme il s'est développé
pendant les deux mois qui viennent de
s'écouler
donc c'est toujours un train tôt tard
peut-être que ce sera la bonne décision
pour justement éviter le tri des malades
et éviter la saturation de la
réanimation mais pourquoi si tard c'est
toujours cette question qui sera posée
est d'ailleurs demain nous aurons
l'occasion de l'évoquer dans le cadre de
du débat que nous aurons à l'assemblée
nationale le matin et au sénat l'après
midi avec le premier ministre
enfin un débat sur le fond et justement
ce débat sera une sorte de vote de
confiance de la part des parlementaires
envers la stratégie sanitaire du
gouvernement
vous allez voter contre on ne sait pas à
ce stade tout d'abord il faut se
connaître
les annonces tant du président que du
premier ministre premièrement
deuxièmement si on veut piéger le
parlement par un vote en disant mais
finalement on se fie vos avis avec deux
mois de retard
ça peut être mortifère pour le parlement
qui considérerait que finalement il est
instrumentalisé
je ne souhaite pas trace totalisé mais
c'est une décision collective que nous
prendrons ce soir avec le groupe de
l'assemblée nationale merci beaucoup
patrick a l'air d'avoir répondu à mes
questions c'est imbattable
merci beaucoup alexandre et tout de
suite on va rejoindre jean mathia notre
streamer politique et a bien suivi toute
cette séance
qu'est ce que tu as pensé et bien de
l'ambiance qu'il ya eu dans cette séance
on le disait on est encore suspendus aux
annonces des manuels ma croix à 20
heures il ya eu beaucoup de questions et
on a peu restés sur notre faim au niveau
des réponses ou pour toi ya quand même
eu quelques indices écoute
il ya eu des indices en tout cas les
internautes on notait la colère froide
de bernard jomier bernard jaume i et
sénateurs très intéressant puisque
rapporteur de la commission d' enquête
sur la gestion du co lead est par
ailleurs lui-même médecin il était à
l'hôpital de melun il a vu lui même le
manque de moyens à l'hôpital et donc on
a noté cette colère froide de bernard
jomier qui a reproché personnellement
emmanuel macron de jouer avec la vie des
français d'être responsable et a
pratiquement dit que le président de la
république a du sang sur les mains et on
a vu aussi le gouvernement tenté de
répondre en expliquant que les choses
sont quand même gérer bon an mal an que
les les lits sont créées par des
programmations à l'hôpital
ça n'a pas vraiment tu t'en doutes créer
créer le créole enthousiasme sur le chat
ici sur twitch il ya eu aussi le sujet
école qui a été noté par par les
internautes on a vu là aussi jean michel
blanquer a essayé de justifier l'honneur
de la france qui n'a pas fermer ses
écoles et lui s'en enorgueillit beaucoup
la vraie question c'est jusqu'à quand tu
l'as dit de sources parlementaires on
sait qu emmanuel macron annoncera
probablement ce soir une fermeture des
écoles donc est-ce que l'argumentaire de
jean michel blanquer va être mise au
tapis par un président de la république
est ce que est ce que l'argument de la
faible progression du virus dans les
écoles va continuer à tenir sa en rond
se douter on l'a bien vu du côté des
élus là aussi que
j'avais vraiment un doute de ce point de
vue là mais oui bien sûr évidemment jean
michel blanquer sous pression et enfin
on a noté la question sur l'unef la
question du sénateur françois bonhomme
très énervé contre l'unef qui estime que
pour lui ça relève du pénal
on sait que le poker de la république a
été saisi par des parlementaires de
droite et on a vu la réponse du
gouvernement qui tente de défendre bon
an mal an la représentativité de l'unef
tu t'en doutes là aussi les internautes
le débat sur les nefs ça met le feu dans
l'hémicycle du palais du luxembourg
comme sur le chat de twitch ça change
pas et va merci beaucoup aux gens on se
retrouve bien sûr la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement très bonne
journée tout de suite et bien on va
continuer les réactions salle des
conférences et bien notamment à ces
annonces qu'on attend à 20h d'emmanuel
macro et alors que de sources
parlementaires les écoles devraient
fermer pour un mois qu'on sait ce que
l'on attend des annonces ce soir du
président de la république et on va
rejoindre alexandre poussard avec le
président du groupe uc ici au sénat
hervé marseille hervé marseille
selon nos informations le président de
la république pourrait annoncer ce soir
une fermeture des écoles pendant au
moins en mois ce serait un échec pour la
stratégie gouvernement on a cherché par
utile une troisième voie
une spécialisation française visiblement
cette voie là est le même qu en
réanimation donc à l'évidence il faut
revenir à des choses plus habituel en
europe qu'on a pu constater dans
d'autres pays on nous dit que les écoles
vont fermer pendant plusieurs semaines
avec les collèges les lycées
ça va être un gros problème pour les
familles je ne sais pas ce qu'il va en
être d autres contraintes
en tous les cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
on vit une période où il n'est pas
normal qu'ils aient un homme qui est 17
qui décide seul dans son palais de ce
qu'il faut faire ou pas faire sans
écouter ni les autorités scientifiques
sans consulter le parlement
songez que il va peut-être intervenir ce
soir pour dire ce qu'il veut faire
ça va être attendu par des millions de
familles françaises et puis demain on va
nous demander notre avis ça n'a ni queue
ni tête
et justement et qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce débat qui aura lieu demain
au parlement selon vous il aurait fallu
faire un débat au parlement avant les
décisions du président de la république
si on vous demande votre avis si avant
de prendre une décision si vous prenez
une décision et qu'on demande votre avis
après j'ai pas comment ça s'appelle mais
ça s'appelle une consultation
donc c'est de l'affichage je suis pas ce
que c'est c'est bizarre en tout cas
normalement vous allez être consulté sur
les régionales un report est inévitable
sans vous et là encore il s'agit d'un
élément de démocratie c'est quand même
pas rien que de savoir quand on vote
comment on vote à rythme régulier c'est
un problème de légitimité
c'est important aussi pour la relance
puisque les régions participent
largement à la relance on sait pas à
quelques semaines près si on va voter ou
pas il ya des dates normalement on doit
voter c'est ce qu'ont fait partout en
europe
le message est clair merci beaucoup
merci hervé marseille pour votre
réaction merci merci beaucoup aux
élections dont a senti le grand
agacement d'hervé marseille le président
du groupe centriste
ici au sénat nouvelles réactions celle
de la sénatrice communiste céline brulin
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle interpellé le gouvernement
autour de la question des écoles c'est
vraiment l'un des sujets centraux sur
lequel on attend des annonces ce soir
alexandre aouita mais c'était d'ailleurs
alors des moments forts de cette séance
de questions d'actualité cette question
de céline brulin sur la situation
sanitaire dans les écoles et d'ailleurs
le président la république
aurait annoncé ce soir une fermeture des
écoles avec un allongement des vacances
scolaires ça signifierait l'échec du
gouvernement sur sa stratégie sanitaire
dans les écoles bah ça veut dire
clairement qu'on n'a pas engagé la
politique de tests qu'il aurait fallu
pour pouvoir isoler les enfants et les
enseignants à chaque fois que nécessaire
et pour que le virus se contaminent le
moins possible ça veut dire qu'on n'a
pas entendu la nécessité de vacciner les
personnels je pense enseignants mais
aussi les messages des assistants
d'éducation et personnels des
collectivités et fermer les écoles mais
si tout ça ne se met pas en place très
rapidement ce sera à reculer pour mieux
sauter alors juste si on compare avec le
2ème confinement de l'automne on avait
d'une certaine manière confiner les
adultes mais garder les enfants à
l'école
là avec les dernières mesures sanitaires
on n'a pas confiner les adultes et là on
annoncerait que les enfants que les
écoles vont fermer c'est à dire que
l'école n'est plus la priorité
comment pourrait l'interpréter je crois
que ça veut dire si c'est confirmé c'est
que à nouveau le gouvernement et le
président de la république et c'est de
chercher des confinement qui n'en porte
pas le nom parce que si on annonce aux
parents d'élèves que dès lundi
je ne sais pas si ce sera ça mais si dès
lundi leurs enfants ne vont plus à
l'école il va falloir évidemment qu'ils
s'organisent pour les garder et donc ça
veut dire qu'un certain nombre de
salariés ne pourront plus aller
travailler
c'est un confinement ou en tout cas ça y
ressemble beaucoup
en tout cas sur le ton de jean michel
blanc car il avait l'air satisfait
d'avoir gardé les écoles ouvertes depuis
septembre est ce que c'est quand même
une réussite pour la jav idée vous les
autres voisins - moi je pense que la
place des enfants est évidemment à
l'école mais en toute sécurité
évidemment toute sécurité pour les
personnels aussi mais la marque de
fabrique de ce gouvernement c'est quand
même l'auto satisfaction permanente
personne ne dit que c'est facile à gérer
une crise pareille
mais le mieux c'est quand même on
concertent on consulte on associe les
premiers concernés
encore une fois on nous annonce des
protocoles du jour pour le lendemain on
a des mères qui ne savent plus où donner
de la tête des enseignants qui sont
épuisés
on ne peut pas fonctionner comme ça il
faut se mettre autour de la table et
regardez ce qu'il est utile de faire et
organiser les choses à voir des
stratégies et c'est ce qui manque
terriblement finalement gouvernement et
jean michel blanchard n'écoute pas les
acteurs de l'éducation sur cette
question sanitaire dans les écoles ah
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire parce
que par exemple sur la vaccination ça
fait des mois et des mois maintenant que
les personnels demandent à être vaccinés
et on peut les comprendre ils sont au
contact de beaucoup d'enfants
et puis il me semble aussi qu'il faut
que jean michel blanquer entendent qu'on
ne peut pas supprimer des postes on ne
peut pas fermer des classes à la
prochaine rentrée
parce que le conseil scientifique dans
le rapport qu'il a encore rendu ces
jours-ci dit que l'épidémie ne sera
malheureusement peut-être pas
complètement derrière nous à l'automne
et donc on ne peut pas imaginer d'avoir
des classes à 30 est plus dans le
contexte
merci à mes questions merci merci
beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
réactions celle des conférences on a
bien senti que les parlementaires de
tous les bords ne se sentent guère
associés à la gestion de cette crise et
que les estime qu'il ya une trop grande
solitude du président de la république
dans les prises
[Musique]